In der Sprache, die ich benutze, ist sehr archänisch. Ich weiß, dass ihr politisch sein wollt. Ich hab einen rufen Sieg gemacht, und so weit, wie ich kann, ist es meistens eine gute Liste, ungefähr jede 10 Sekunden. Auf Wiedersehen! Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 61. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ihr hört Chaosradio Express, den Podcast vom Chaos Computer Club, der immer häufiger erscheint. Man mag es gar nicht glauben. Wir haben den 21. Dezember 2007, nur noch wenige Tage, bis ja Weihnachten, Nordweihnachten vom 27. bis zum 30. Dezember, dem Chaos Communication Kongress. Aber dieses Mal, die letzten drei Sendungen hatten alle mehr oder weniger mit dem Kongress zu tun, aber dieses Mal widmen wir uns wieder ganz einem anderen Thema. Ein Thema, was viele Leute immer sehr verwirrt und wo sehr viel durcheinander gebracht wird, wo Missverständnisse entstehen und wo vor allem eine ganze Menge religiöse Kriege ausgefochten werden, das kommt dann eigentlich gleich nach Betriebssystemen. Die Rede ist von Medienformaten bzw. von Codex, um ein bisschen genauer zu sein und zu werden. Und damit ich auch so richtig schön genau werden kann, habe ich mir Michael Feiri dazugeladen. Wir sitzen ja jetzt hier gerade in Ulm, bin zu Besuch in Ulm und habe auch gerade erfahren, dass ich dann am Sonntag beim Dev-Radio mit reinhören darf. Dev-Radio ist ein Projekt des Chaos-Computer-Club Ulms und zum Chaos-Computer-Club Ulm gehörst du dazu. Seit wann?
Auch seit ich in der Uni Ulm studiere, also, ohje, ohje, hätte ich nicht sagen sollen.
Seit einer Generation sozusagen.
Also das macht die Uni erdrächtlich, ja.
Der CCC Ulm ist ja eine der längsten Erfarkreise oder Subgruppen oder Regionalvertretungen, wie man das auch mal nennen möchte, des Clubs. Lustigerweise, weil ja der Club vor allem so zu der Zeit, als der CCC Ulm sich schon gegründet hat, ja, eigentlich extrem verwurzelt in Hamburg saß und kaum etwas könnte jetzt weiter auseinander sein, also weiter voneinander entfernt sein, rein geografisch gesehen, als eben jetzt die beiden Städte. Von daher war das immer recht bemerkenswert, dass sich der CCC Ulm eigentlich so lange gehalten hat. Du bist gut jetzt nicht von Anfang an dabei gewesen, sondern, wie wir gerade gehört haben, sechs Jahre vor sechs Jahren dazugestoßen. Aber nichtsdestotrotz, der Club lebt noch und hat seine Aktivitäten. Was gibt es da im Wesentlichen? Also das Dev-Radio-Projekt ist wahrscheinlich eines der ressourcenfressendsten Dinge, oder?
Ja, es ist zweitressourcenfressendste. Die Chaos-Seminar, die wir veranstalten, sind eigentlich das Größte, was wir so haben.
Was macht ihr da?
Naja, wir haben jeden Monat, am zweiten Montag im Monat ein Chaos-Seminar. Da haben wir einen Hörsaal in der Uni und treffen uns und suchen uns jemanden raus, entweder extern, jemand, den wir einladen oder einer von uns, der ein Thema bespricht, irgendeins, was gerade anliegt. Also von Windows-Firewalls, was dann sogar ziemlich groß durch die Online-Welt gegangen ist, bis hin zu, ich glaube, das Wildeste, was wir mal hatten, waren dann Industrie-Spionage oder Rollenspiele, von Technik bis Politik. Wir hatten RMS mal bei uns, Stormen, das war zu der Zeit von den Software-Patenten.
Oh je, gehörst du zu den armen Leuten, die ihn betreuen mussten?
Leid, zu Glück nicht, aber ich habe entsprechend dies ausgehört, das ist toll.
Ja, mich haben alle Leute, die irgendwie ihn betreuen mussten, haben mich danach immer gefragt, warum sie denn keiner gewarnt hätten. Von daher, ihr seid jetzt alle gewarnt, aber naja, er hat ja durchaus was beizutragen zu der einen oder anderen Diskussion. Vielleicht weniger zu der, die wir heute führen wollen. Also bei diesem Chaos-Seminar bist du da auch technisch mit dabei, nehme ich an, bei den Mitschnitten, das heißt, ihr veröffentlicht das auch als Podcast, richtig?
Richtig, genau.
Sogar mehrere Podcasts, es gibt auch die Slides, glaube ich, als PDF, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Fasst du das einfach mal zusammen, weil es ist ja eh besser als ich.
Ja, wir hatten eine ganze Reihe von Format-Podcasts, also der gleiche Inhalt in unterschiedlichen Feeds, in unterschiedlichen Formaten. Angefangen von MPEG-4, das war von Anfang an im Prinzip unser Standard-Format. In großen und kleinen Varianten hatten wir das zwischendurch mal. Dann hatten wir, seit RMS speziell, hatten wir das Ganze auch in freien Formaten, in patentfreien Formaten, hoffentlich patentfreien Formaten. Genau, richtig, richtig. Das heißt, wir hatten dann einen großen MPEG-4, einen kleinen MPEG-4, MPEG-3-Versionen, Teora-Versionen, Vaubis-Versionen, also audio-only, plus noch einen PDF-Feed und dann noch einen Kombinations-Feed aus MPEG-4 plus PDF. Also in Spitzenzeiten. Ich glaube, wir hatten sogar zwischendurch noch mal einen 3GP-Feed. Da hatte ich dann gerade neu ein Handy bekommen, was 3GP abspielen konnte. Dann hatte ich mir den Spaß erlaubt, ein paar Monate lang einen 3GP-Feed zu machen.
Was das ist, da wären wir noch zu kommen. Aber was ist denn davon am populärsten?
MPEG-4, weil das auch bei uns in unserem Fall der größte ist. Also das ist das Format mit der besten Qualität.
Meinst du, dass die Leute jetzt mehr an der Qualität interessiert sind, als an einem bestimmten Format?
Ja, das nennt man schon. Also lustigerweise haben wir in unserer speziellen Zielgruppe eine sehr starke Org-Fraktion. Also wir haben, lass mich lügen, in Prozent, was haben wir, ein Drittel, glaube ich, abonniert sich auch Vorbis oder Teora kombiniert. Aber der Rest ist halt MPEG-3, MPEG-4. Und auf der Schiene haben wir auch das meiste Know-how und können auch besser optimieren. Teora läuft im Prinzip so nebenher, weil es halt Leute haben wollen und mein Gott, es macht uns keine große Arbeit und wenn sie dann glücklich sind, dann machen wir eben auch noch ein kleines Transcoding nach Teora. Wir haben ja keine so großen Probleme mit Metadaten, weil bei uns läuft das alles über ein Feed. Wir haben in den Movie-Containern selbst nicht wirklich viel an Metadaten drin. Ich glaube, wir haben gar nichts drin, wenn ich ganz ehrlich sein soll. Wir machen das alles über extern, das heißt der Feed ist eine XML-Beschreibung von den Episoden, die in dem Feed drin liegen und da sind dann die Metadaten drin bei uns. Insofern können wir uns das locker leisten. Wir hauen einfach alles durch einen Transcoder durch und dann schmeißen wir es raus.
Und gut ist. Also mit anderen Worten, war das jetzt dein erstes Zusammentreffen mit dem Thema Media-Formate? Du bist auch schon länger, oder?
Ja, ich bin schon länger dabei. Also ich habe halt als ganz normaler End-User, Mitte der 90er schon, ein bisschen mit QuickM experimentiert gehabt, weil mich das interessiert hatte, weil ich das spaßig fand. Da gab es auch noch Multimedia, das sagt heute ja kein Mensch mehr, aber das war damals halt auch noch ein großes Thema und mit QuickM, wir haben eigene Panoramen fotografiert und die dann zusammengestitcht, was man alles machen konnte, das war ja alles ganz witzig damals. Plus, ich habe in meiner Dotcom-Zeit auch bei einem Startup gearbeitet, wo es darum ging, Video, Food zu machen, auf Handhelds, was man halt so machen konnte, 2000.
Okay, also bist du schon durch einige Feuer gegangen, nehme ich mal an, in dem Zusammenhang, weil so aus eigener Erfahrung kann ich eigentlich berichten, dass man sich da doch ganz schön die Hände verbrennen kann bei diesen Datenformaten. Kompatibilität ist da ein Problem und natürlich auch das Problem der richtigen Formatwahl. Ich habe ja hier bei Chaosradio auch immer wieder von Zeit zu Zeit die Diskussion, warum ich nicht mehr Formaten anbiete, was bei mir einfach ein Zeitproblem ist. Zumal man eben mit den gewählten Formaten eigentlich auch alle erreicht heutzutage. Die Diskussion will ich aber jetzt nicht führen, die führen wir dann auf den Blog, weil Lus hat da noch ein bisschen mit zu. Reden sei eingeladen bei den einschlägigen Blogpostings auf blog.chaosradio.ch. Aber was wir jetzt mal so ein bisschen versuchen wollen hier ist, oder was ich vielmehr versuchen wollte, ist ein bisschen Licht in den Nebel zu bringen. Der Nebel ist einfach der, dass häufig viele Dinge durcheinander gebracht werden. Es wird halt von MPEG-4 gesprochen und der eine meint das Dateiformat, der andere meint den Codec, ein Dritter redet wiederum von dem Audio, es ist alles durcheinander. Von daher ist es natürlich erstmal wichtig, so ein bisschen Begriffsklärung zu betreiben. Ich weiß gar nicht, wer hat eigentlich angefangen, Mediendateien, also wo liegt denn der Ursprung eigentlich in diesem ganzen Bild- und Ton-Ding? Also ich meine, die ersten Mediendateien, die ich kenne, also die wirklich so im Internet auch verfügbar waren, das waren eigentlich diese Aufheils von Sun. Weil diese Sun-Workstation hatte halt so ein Mikrofon eingebaut, das war irgendwie ein ganz großer Hype, das muss so Anfang der 90er Jahre gewesen sein, ja also bis dahin hatte man einfach nicht auch nur im Traum daran gedacht, Audio auf einem Computer abzuspielen, weil das einfach unmäßig große Dateien sind und überhaupt das Processing von Audio war natürlich für die CPUs damals noch eine ziemliche Herausforderung, von daher war es einfach mal nicht üblich. Dann kam das aber eben auf, unser erstes populäres Format war eigentlich dieses Punkt-Auf-Format, was halt nichts anderes war als das MyLaw, also das amerikanische Telefonencoding, bei uns in Europa wird ja A-Law verwendet und die Qualität hat es dann auch, aber das war dann so das erste, was irgendwie herumflog. Mitte der 90er Jahre kam dann irgendwann Apple mit seinem QuickTime auf und ich glaube, das war dann auch so ein bisschen der Beginn von allem, oder liege ich da falsch?
Ja, also was die End-Jewel trifft, ja, das stimmt schon, vor allem auch noch online, klar. Also da gab es Anfang der 90er dann die ersten Sachen, die online verfügbar waren zum Downloaden, mal abgesehen von irgendwelchen System-Sounds, System-Beeps, wobei das glaube ich am Anfang auch ein Ding war, was man gerne gemacht hat, weil sonst mehr machen konnte man ja nicht, also große zwei-Stunden-Interviews runterladen, hat man ja auch nicht gemacht am Anfang. Da hatte man sich dann, das weiß ich sogar auch noch, das war ja die Zeit, wo ich selber angefangen habe, mit den ganzen Mac-Sachen damals, lustige Sounds auf alle möglichen Aktionen drauflegen, zum Beispiel Diskette auswerfen, dann kann man so ein lustiger Sound oder sonstige Sachen machen, beim Papierkoppeln lernen, ob man sich irgendwelche Sounds abspielen lassen kann.
Die Müllabfuhr kommt.
Ja, ganz genau, richtig. So hat es bei mir angefangen, das war auch ungefähr Anfang der 19er, wobei ich glaube ich dann schon, was war das für ein Format, also auf dem Mac-Band wahrscheinlich noch diese Sound-Resourcen. SND, richtig.
Ja. Aber wir wollen jetzt hier nicht so einen historischen Wohlfühl-Podcast machen. Also QuickTime war das erste System, was eigentlich Teil eines Betriebssystems war und was gesagt hat, hallo, wir machen jetzt mal einen Standard oder vereinheitlichen, Standard ist vielleicht ein bisschen weit hergeholt, wir vereinheitlichen zumindest innerhalb des Betriebssystems die Art und Weise, wie mit zeitbasierten Daten umgegangen wird. Das ist ja eigentlich auch das, was da drin steht. Deswegen heißt es ja QuickTime. Mediendaten sind halt Daten, die eben Daten auf einer Zeitachse arrangieren, also Bilder auf Zeit, Lautstärke auf Zeit, das ist das, was dort gemacht wird und hat das eben in so einem kompletten Framework gemacht, wie das bei Apple dann eben üblich ist, gleich mit dem ganzen Tramram drum herum, also User Interface, Programmierschnittstellen, aber eben dann auch Dateiformaten. Was war das dann bei QuickTime? MOF.
Genau.
Und QuickTime MOF ist eigentlich der erste Vertreter gewesen der sogenannten Containerdateien.
Ja, kann man so sagen.
Was kann man denn jetzt so reintun in so einem Container?
Ja, also die ersten Tracks, die man in den Container reinstecken konnte, waren natürlich dann Audio und Video, um eben zeitgestellte Audio und also Bild und Ton passend zueinander abspielen zu können. Das war damals noch so das berühmte Daumennagelkino in so einer Briefmarkengröße, da hat man dann kleine Filmchen abspielen können. Also wirklich.
Ich glaube so 120 mal 160, das war da gerade so angesagt.
Genau. Aber sie hatten es eben schon als erste im Made-Away-Konsumer-Markt, was halt Apple so bedient. Und das Einzige, was es zu der Zeit auch schon gab, waren die Video-CDs, MPEG-1, die waren auch Anfang der 90er schon unterwegs, aber halt nicht im Computer-Bereich, sondern das waren halt das, was MPEG so klassischerweise gemacht hat, die Standalone-Player.
Was ist denn, also MPEG-1 ist ein, ja was ist denn das, ist das auch ein Containerformat?
Es ist ein ganzes Paket von Sachen, also die MPEG-Leute veröffentlichen immer so ein ganzes Bündel an.
Also vielleicht nochmal kurz erklären, was MPEG eigentlich ist. Also die Motion Picture Experts Group ist so eine Gruppe, die halt irgendwann mal zusammengerufen wurde und gesagt hat, Leute, wir haben ein Problem, das heißt Video löst es und Audio natürlich, um halt einfach digitale Datenformate für Bild und Ton zu kriegen. Und MPEG-1 ist so der allererste Standard, der aus diesem Prozess rausgefallen ist, richtig? Und was ist da rausgefallen?
Bei MPEG-1 war es glaube ich noch der reine Transportstream. Das ist also der reine Datenstrom, der dann durchgeht mit Audio und Video. Ich glaube Interleaf war das dann einfach verwoben, kommt ein Stück Audio, ein Stück Video und damit man es eben zu gleichen Zeit präsent hat und es abspielen kann.
Das ist diese Muxerei, die man immer wieder liest, ne?
Ja, Muxen ist eher multiplexen, Muxen ist im Prinzip ein Oberbegriff für alles. Das kann dann einfach nur ein Transportstream sein oder ein Bitstream sein, ein Container sein, das ist dann schonmal da alles eigentlich.
Okay, also Transportstream geht so ein bisschen davon aus, dass ja eigentlich diese ganzen Standards auch dafür gemacht werden, dass der ganze Kram vom Satteläden runterfällt, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Oder aus dem Fernsehsender irgendwie digital.
Oder von der CD reingeladen wird's.
Und was heißt das, ich meine, auch in einem normalen Container ist doch alles miteinander verwoben. Also was ist da jetzt der Unterschied?
Ja, aber der Trick ist, ich kann, wenn ich möchte, die Spuren auch einzeln anfassen.
In welchem Fall?
In einem Container.
Ja, okay. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo es gemultiplext ist oder interleaved ist, wie hast du gesagt, interweaved, interleaved?
Interleaving, also...
In dem Moment ist es so miteinander verdings, dass man Ton und Bild sich immer gleichzeitig betrachten muss, so als Programm, so mein Leben als Programm, um irgendwie ranzukommen. Dann muss man das selber auseinandersortieren. Aber das muss man doch sowieso. Also ich meine, auch wenn es jetzt im Container, da steht das Video, da steht das Audio, macht es das jetzt nur einfacher oder ist da irgendwie konzeptionell irgendwas ganz anders?
Im Prinzip macht es es einfach mal nur einfacher.
Okay. Also es ist sozusagen dafür, das Medienformat ist so gemacht, dass es einfacher ist, sich das einzeln rauszuholen. Weil ich sehe immer, wenn immer so was gemuxt ist, dann muss man halt erstmal irgendwelche Demuxer starten, die dann erstmal Bild und Ton auseinanderhalten und damit man das irgendwie einzeln hat. Also der Mehrwert ist nicht so ganz klar, wie diese Vermuxung, wie weit die geht, also wie kompliziert das nun wirklich ist.
Ja, letzten Endes, wenn es auf die Platte serialisiert wird, dann wird es auch irgendwie in einer Form vermuxt. Aber der Mehrwert, den ich durch diese Container-Formate bekomme, ist, dass sich diese Trailer, die Texttracks, im Prinzip beliebig reinnehmen kann, rausnehmen kann, mehrere Texts reintun kann. Zum Beispiel, was eine ganz frühe Einwendung gewesen war, waren mehrere Tonspuren reinzumachen, um beispielsweise eine deutsche und eine englische Tonspur zu haben, oder dass ich einen Texttrack mit reinnehmen kann.
Also Untertitel.
Genau, Untertitel zu bekommen, richtig. Und so eine Flexibilität bietet mir einfach so ein blanker Transportstream nicht, da ist halt Frame für Frame, kommt dann halt Bild, Ton und das war's.
Das ist sozusagen so Fernsehen, wie man es so kennt. Und QuickTime war also jetzt mit seinem MOV oder Movie-Format, QuickTime Movie-Format eigentlich das erste wirkliche Container-Format, was auch daraufhin ausgerichtet war, nicht nur abgespielt zu werden, sondern eben auch als Quelle zu dienen, sprich für Leute, die jetzt Content erstellen, einfach zu markieren, hier fängt es an, da hält es auf, Copy und Paste und dann konnte man das irgendwie alles so einverstanden. Ich kann mich auch noch ganz gut an diese Daumen-Kino-Zeit erinnern. Da saß ich auch irgendwie vor meinem alten Macintosh 2Ci und fand das irgendwie alles ganz toll, dass es jetzt irgendwie so geht und so. Man konnte dann halt einfach so den Film nehmen und so Cut und Paste machen. Total großartig. Ich meine, das habe ich auch bis heute noch nirgendswo anders gesehen. Es war einfach erstaunlich, wie einfach man auf einmal damit arbeiten konnte. Allerdings gab es auch bestimmte Dinge, da hat das halt irgendwie nie so richtig funktioniert. Also so Untertitel ist mir heute noch ein Rätsel.
Ja, die Bedienung, so etwas einzufügen, ist immer noch so ein Ding. Also gerade speziell das Problem bei Apple war immer, dass sie diese ganze Bearbeitung von vielen dieser speziellen Tracks, die es gegeben hat, auf Third Parties abgewälzt haben nach dem Motto, ja, macht mal hier, das ist ein potenzieller Markt, macht mal ein paar Programme. Und es sind auch ein paar gekommen, aber das ist nie wirklich so abgehoben, wie es vielleicht hätte abheben können. Also ich kenne ein paar Vertreter aus der Ecke, Electrify zum Beispiel, das war so ein Ding. Oder Shareprogramme gab es eine ganze Reihe, zum Beispiel gerade für solche Untertitel, um sowas zu machen. QuickTime VR war witzigerweise relativ erfolgreich, aber so wirklich abgehoben hat die ganze Sache nicht. Obwohl in den Jahren ja Multimedia so ein Hype war und jeder alles machen wollte, ist in dieser QuickTime-Szene das nie wirklich so toll geworden, wie es hätte werden können. Und Apple selber hat komischerweise nichts gemacht in der Richtung.
Ja, merkwürdig, wie du schon gesagt hast, dann hob es ab, dann ging es irgendwie so ein bisschen los und irgendwann haben alle gesehen, oh Gott, AV, Daten, damit müssen wir irgendwie alle klarkommen und auf einmal gab es einen totalen Wildwuchs der Systeme. Wäre es eigentlich so, also meine MPEG, den Standard, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wann ging das los mit MPEG 1, also wann haben die so ihren ersten Standard abgelegt, weißt du das?
Also ich meine, ich hatte mal eine Timeline für ein Chaos-Seminar, da hatte ich Quicktime und MPEG in den ersten Versionen so um 91, 90, 91 veranschlagt, dass die auch wirklich öffentlich gemacht wurden und dann in Benutzung gewesen sind.
Aber es hat dann eine Weile gedauert, bis das wirklich so auf Computer dann auch wirklich reinkam.
Ja, also wirklich abgehoben bei Computern speziell Audio hat Midreal im Internet, also Mitte der 90er, 95 ungefähr, wo es dann Internet auch ein bisschen bei den Leuten angekommen ist oder zumindest angefangen hat, bei den Leuten anzukommen. 95, 96, 97, da gab es ganz bekannt die Real Audio Streams. Das ist dann schon im Prinzip die zweite Generation. Da kam Video vor Windows und eben Real und da ging es richtig rund. Also gerade Real, da haben dann die ersten großen Radiostationen angefangen, ins Internet zu streamen. Ja, da war richtig Highlife.
Ja, Real kam zu einem interessanten Zeitpunkt und hat dann, das fand ich schon ganz interessant, dass Apple sich da die Butter vom Brot nehmen lassen, obwohl sie eigentlich mit den Technologien schon viel weiter waren. Real hat, glaube ich, das, was sie richtig gemacht haben, waren, dass sie einfach einen Codec gebaut haben, der so halbwegs akzeptable Qualität bei sehr geringer Datenbandbreite gemacht hat, während Apple eigentlich sehr viel mehr auf diesen Multimedia-CD-ROM-Sektor festgelegt war, wo man mit ganz anderen Datenraten arbeiten konnte. Das war natürlich Mitte der 90er Jahre unmöglich, im Internet solche Datenbandbreiten vorauszusetzen, wie sie dafür benötigt worden wären. Und dadurch wurde es auf einmal so ein Erfolg.
Ja, also die Zielrichtung war einfach eine ganz andere. Man hatte bei Apple dann im Kicktime, ich glaube, das EMA-Format war damals noch aktuell für Audio. Das ist so eine 4 zu 1-Kompensation gewesen, glaube ich. Und Real hat einfach das Ganze noch viel kleiner bekommen, um es dann überhaupt einfach nur machbar zu machen, das wirklich live im Internet. Also live war ja überhaupt eine ganz neue Dimension, die man danach hatte. Das gab es ja vorher noch gar nicht, dass man live Audio übertragen konnte in Echtzeit quasi, abgesehen von ein paar buffering Sekunden, die man danach tragen musste.
Oh ja, also jetzt wo du das sagst, das war ja wirklich ein Riesenhype. Ich weiß noch mal, hier gab es, glaube ich, ein Orbital-Konzert in Berlin, wo dann auch irgendwie auf Plakaten fett angekündigt wurde. Ja, hier, wir live im Internet, weißt du noch, als so Cyberspace, als es irgendwie so losging. Man brauchte nur Internet sagen, da sind alle schon so wie von Gas betäubt, so leicht nach hinten, so wirklich Internet, Cyberspace, unglaublich. Leute in Weltraumanzügen und so. Ich hab dann so hintenrum danach von den Leuten, die das gemacht haben, gehört, dass irgendwie so fünf Leute oder so live im Internet dann auch tatsächlich zugehört haben und das sicherlich auch nicht mehr gemacht haben, als zu testen, ob es geht. Aber mittlerweile sind wir ja da, dass so die Direktbildübertragung gar kein Thema mehr ist. Auch der Kongress streamt ja alles ganz fleißig weg. Und es wird auch angeguckt. Also viele Leute verfolgen den Kongress live. Ja, so, okay. Dann bleiben wir vielleicht kurz bei dieser historischen Timeline. Also Reel Audio kam mit ins Boot. Und irgendwann musste er sich dann ja auch mal Microsoft bewegen.
Ja, klar. Also die hatten natürlich dann auch bald gesehen, nach den ersten Befolgungen von QuickTime, so brauchen wir auch dringend. Und so dann Video for Windows hieß das damals, ins Leben gerufen. Also Video-Abspielmöglichkeiten unter Windows zu integrieren, eben auch auf Betriebssystemebene, um halt konkurrenzfähig zu sein. Da hatten sie dann auch ganz interessante Kooperationen mit Intel. Den bekannten Indio-Codec gab es dann dabei, was sehr erfolgreich gewesen ist, war auch nicht schlecht. Ja, und da hat sich dann schon im Prinzip der Format VIRVAR gezeigt. Die hatten dann...
Okay, jetzt wollte ich mal kurz einhaken, weil jetzt sind eigentlich alle Stichworte gefallen. Jetzt hatten wir so diese Container-Formate, also sozusagen, wie ist ein Datei aufgebaut, um Bild und Ton aufzunehmen, wenn man schon gesagt hat, man kann damit Tracks irgendwie modellieren, man trägt dazu oder lässt den weg. Und der Tracker hat einen bestimmten Typ, der ist Video oder ist Audio oder ist Text oder was auch immer. Und dann haben wir die Codecs. Da sollte man das einfach nochmal genau auseinanderhalten. Was macht, wofür ist das Container-Format zuständig, und wofür ist der Codec zuständig?
Der Codec ist rein für die Komposition. Codec setzt sich zusammen aus kompromieren, dekompromieren, also kodieren, dekodieren, Codec. Zum Beispiel von Audiodaten oder Videodaten. Oder vielleicht ist es auch Textdaten. Irgendeine Form von Kodierung für Text ist im Prinzip auch ein Codec. Ich kann einen ASCII-Codec angeben oder davon reden als Codec. Jeder Track, der in so einem Container drin steckt, ist in der Regel eine Beschreibung von irgendeiner Art von Datum, irgendeiner Art von Daten. Und die müssten in irgendeinem Format vorliegen. Sprich, bei Audio hatten wir schon Ailer und Mühler angesprochen. Das wären jetzt mal klassische Codecs für Audio gewesen. Bei Video war damals zum Beispiel Cinepak ein aktueller Codec. Reel hatte dann einfach nach ihrer Plattform das Reel Audio und Reel Video genannt und dann war es sonst nochmal dran gehängt.
Hat Reel denn auch so ein Container-Format?
Ich glaube, die haben auch nur blanke Bitstreams rausgehauen. Also man braucht es auch, wenn man nur einfach Audio raushaut, so schnell wie es irgendwie geht, dann brauche ich auch nie wirklich einen Container drum herum machen. Ich habe dann vorne vielleicht noch ein paar Bites für Header-Informationen und Autortitel und das war es dann. Das brauche ich im Prinzip auch wirklich nicht.
Sondern wenn es live ist, braucht man nur einen Transport zu drehen. Das ist ja klar. Aber heutzutage arbeitet man mit den Dateien ja auch lokal oder eben wie hier beim Podcast per Download. Da kommt die Datei halt erstmal an und man will dann eben damit auch flexibel umgehen können. Also ich will das zumindest und viele andere wollen das auch. Okay, und was hatte Microsoft?
Die hatten mit Video Verwendung das ABI-Format. ABI steht für Audio, Video Interleaved. Also das ist im Prinzip schon klar, wo es hingeht. Man hat halt Audio und Video und packt das zusammen und schickt es raus. Und es funktioniert. Und funktioniert bis heute zu gut, weil es immer noch von Leuten benutzt wird, obwohl es nicht mehr wirklich up to date ist. Ist auch von Microsoft selbst schon seit Jahren, ich glaube 96, 97, nicht mehr weiterentwickelt worden. Es gibt dann Weiterentwicklungen von irgendwelchen anderen Firmen, die dann Unterstützung für größere Dateigrößen hinzugefügt haben, also mehr als zwei Gigabytes.
Aber es gibt keinen Standard dafür.
Naja, also diese Erweiterungen sind halt well known. Man kennt es, man weiß, wie das aussieht, und dann kann man das auch unterstützen. Das ist also nicht so schlimm.
Das ist so well known, dass es auch Webseiten gibt, auf denen das dann steht, wie es wirklich ist. Okay, ich hatte manchmal den Eindruck, das steht eigentlich nur im Source-Code von irgendwelchen Abspielprogrammen, die das unterstützen. Weil das ist sehr häufig so, dass man einfach so Details über bestimmte Formate einfach nicht rankommt. Dass es einfach sehr, sehr, sehr schwierig ist, an die little details dann auch wirklich ranzukommen, um da eine zuverlässige Dekodierung zu machen, was dann eben zu diesem hohen Grad an Inkompatibilitäten führt. Also auch bei AVI. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele unterschiedliche AVI-Files ich in meinem Leben schon gesehen habe, aber die Zahl ist locker. Zehnstellig so hoch ist es nicht. Aber zweistellig ist sie auf jeden Fall. Also wo immer wieder ganz andere Probleme auftraten, was da alles irgendwie nicht funktionierte, was auf dem einen Player irgendwie ging, auf dem anderen nicht ging. Und umso mehr man das irgendwie im Kreis schaffelte, umso unklarer war eigentlich, was eigentlich wirklich dafür verantwortlich ist, dass es nicht geht. Das wird ja auch nie gesagt. Die Programme stürzen dann irgendwie ab oder sagen Error minus drei und gute Nacht. Gibt es da irgendwie Erkenntnisse, was eigentlich jetzt bei Avi das Problem ist?
Ja, also solche Sachen, die du jetzt gerade ansprichst, das sind typischerweise Probleme beispielsweise mit den Bezeichnungen von Tracks. Es gibt da sogenannte Four-CCs, Four-Character-Codes. Das sind vier Bytes. Da steht ein Bezeichner drin, was für eine Art Codec verwendet wurde, um hier beispielsweise Video oder Auto reinzupacken. Und nachdem das Format offiziell nicht mehr unterstützt worden ist, hat auch niemand irgendwie ein zentrales Verzeichnis gepflegt, um zu sagen, okay, dieses Format bekommt jetzt diesen Namen und haltet euch alle dran. Gibt's einfach nicht. Und seitdem ist Wild wuchs. Ganz klar.
Aber diese Four-CCs, die gibt's doch immer noch?
Die gibt's immer noch. Die gibt's im Prinzip auch. In allen Formaten, in irgendeiner Form. Ich muss dann meinen Content und meinen Tracks irgendeine Art von Bezeichnungen geben, damit dann ein Player, der das aufmacht, wissen kann.
Weißt du, wo das herkommt?
Four-CC?
Was das erste Format war, was das gemacht hat, das weiß sie nämlich jetzt zufällig. Das kommt vom Amiga. Und zwar war das das Image-File-Format. Aus dem dann später so was wie TIFF, Tiff Tagged Image-File-Format wurde. Oder auch das AIFF, das Audio-Format von Apple. Oder eben auch WAF, was eigentlich RIF heißt. Und die verwenden halt alle dieses selbe Baumsystem, um die Daten dort unterzubringen und sozusagen die Tracks dort abzubilden. Und die haben dann halt mal diese Fossities eingeführt, was letzten Endes nichts anderes als so ein 32-Bit-Wert ist. Und dann hat er gesagt, der wird jetzt durch vier ASCII-Zeichen sozusagen zusammengebaut. Das heißt, man nimmt sich die vier Zeichen, damit hat man zwar nicht die volle Bandbreite von 32 Bit, aber die braucht man auch nicht, weil man eigentlich nur mehrere hundert irgendwie so im Sinne hatte. Und dafür reicht es halt vollkommen aus. Also meinst du, das Hauptproblem bei AVI ist jetzt, dass diese Fossities nicht standardisiert sind.
Ja, das kommen noch viele Sachen dazu. Zum Beispiel, wenn ich ganz neue Formate wie H264 in einen AVI-Kontent reinmachen möchte, habe ich das Problem, dass ich zum Beispiel B-Frames, waren es glaube ich, gar nicht wirklich so in einem Standard AVI abbilden kann. Da muss ich mir dann wilder Hex überlegen, wie ich dann auf solche B-Frames zugreifen kann. Das sind dann Techniken, dass ein Bild sich nicht nur auf das folgende Bild beziehen kann, sondern auch auf das zukünftige Bild beziehen kann und da schon entgegen kompromiert.
Das lässt das Container-Format nicht zu. Also hat das Container-Format schon auch... Vorhin haben wir ja gesagt, Container-Format, das ist ja nur die Klammer. Der Codec kümmert sich vollständig darum, wie das Bild aussieht. Da möchte man ja meinen, dass egal, wie dieser Codec jetzt funktioniert und wie er so seine Daten speichert, dass er eigentlich in jeden Container mit reinpassen müsste, so wie ich jede Datei in meinen Ordner reinwerfen kann, dem ist nicht der Fall.
Na ja, wenn ich hinreichend drauf rumhecke, dann schon, aber in der Originalversion eben nicht.
Aber ich meine, was fehlt denn da konkret zum Beispiel bei dem AVI, damit es jetzt solche Differenz-Frames nicht abbilden kann? Also warum muss es denn davon überhaupt eine Vorstellung haben?
Du musst in diesem Konterneformat.
Also ich meine, ist jetzt ein B-Frame irgendwie so eine halbe Information, die da irgendwie noch mit verankert werden muss? Oder ist das, weil man da nicht direkt reinspringen kann? Also ist das so dieses, weil das könnte doch der Grund sein, oder? Dass man irgendwie nicht in so einen halben Frame reinspringt, weil man muss im Prinzip auf den Referenz-Frame irgendwie verweisen können, wo das vollständige Bild drin ist, damit die Differenz da nicht sichtbar ist? So was? Ich stocke jetzt so ein bisschen im Heu.
Ja, also der Punkt ist der, wenn du... Also es gibt I-Frames, P-Frames und B-Frames.
Okay, dann erklären wir die doch erstmal.
Und normalerweise ist es so, ich habe halt, ich glaube ein I-Frame war derjenige, der einen vollen Frame abbildet und gut ist. Dann kann ich einfach Frame für Frame die Dinge dekodieren und fertig. Dann gibt es solche partiellen Frames, die beziehen sich noch auf das Bild, was vorher war. Das heißt, ich muss nur die Differenz zwischen dem jetzigen Bild und dem nächsten Bild dekodieren und dann kann ich das nächste Bild anzeigen.
Okay.
Dann muss ich also für das nächste Bild nicht mehr das komplette Bild dekodieren, sondern eben nur die Differenzen und den Sparplatz. Und jetzt gibt es eben noch Bilder, die nicht nur als Differenz auf dem vergangenen Bild aufbauen, sondern auch als Differenz ein zukünftiges Bild hernehmen können. Das heißt, ich muss erst also sich fünf Frames dekodieren, damit ich dann den zweiten Frame anzeigen kann.
Ah, ein Predictive. Okay, alles klar. Jetzt verstehe ich es gerade. Also iFrame steht für Intrabilder, also für nur ein normales Bild. Und P ist sozusagen für Prediction, für die Vorhersage eines Bildes. Und B-Frame ist sozusagen in beide Richtungen eine Vorhersage. Oder beide Richtungen, was auch immer. Das heißt, das B-Frame bezieht sich auf die Zukunft. Das passt ja super zum letzten Podcast. Da haben wir auch sehr viel über Zukunft geredet und über Retrofuturismus. Das ist sozusagen der fleischgewordene Retrofuturismus im Datenformat. Die drei gibt es, ja? Und das ist das, womit sich heutzutage eigentlich alle Codecs irgendwie durchhelfen.
Also man möchte B-Frames durchaus haben. Es gibt Codecs, die das nicht haben. Also es hat nicht jeder Codec alle Features. Es ist auch vielleicht einfach keine gute Idee, so viel in die Zukunft sehen zu müssen, weil man müsste es dann auch alles cashen und vordecodieren. Also gerade diese kleinen portablen Player, die Strom sparen müssen, verzichten ganz gerne auf B-Frames. Da gibt es dann in der Regel bei den großen populären Codec-Familien Profile, die man sich spezifiziert oder Level, die man spezifiziert, damit man innerhalb einer Codec-Familie oder innerhalb eines Codecs sagen kann, ok, dieser Player unterstützt die und die Features. Und ein höherer Player, der dann von mir aus auf der Setup-Box ist und nicht auf dem Handy, der kann dann einige Features mehr, zum Beispiel eben B-Frames.
Ok, jetzt wird es ja sehr technisch. Wir müssen aufpassen, dass wir jetzt hier auch beisammen bleiben. Also wir waren ja bei AVI. Wir haben gesehen, ok, das Containerformat ist zwar nicht das, was letzten Endes wirklich definiert, wie etwas gespeichert ist, weil das machen die Codecs. So, ein Containerformat muss in der Lage sein, diesen Codec zu beherbergen. Aber es gibt auch bestimmte Anforderungen, die ein Codec an ein Containerformat stellt, wie zum Beispiel im Falle dieser B-Frames. Wenn du das und das nicht kannst, dann kann ich meine Daten hier bei dir einfach nicht positionierbar einblenden. Weil es geht ja um die Zuordnung zur Zeit. Das ist ja das, was Containerformat machen muss. Und wenn die Zeit sich so komisch abbilden lässt, weil das Ding zum Beispiel nach hinten und nach vorne guckt, dann muss das Format das eben vorsehen. Weil man will ja da auch reinklicken, markieren, Cut und Paste machen usw. Dann muss er irgendwie in der Lage sein, wenn er sich auf diese eine Stelle konzentriert, eben auch alle notwendigen Daten herbeizuziehen, um zu sagen, ok, das Bild an dieser Stelle ist dieses. Wir sind jetzt auch erstmal nur bei Video-Codex. Und unterschiedliche Codex unterscheiden sich jetzt im Wesentlichen natürlich erstmal durch ihre mathematische Basis, wie sie überhaupt ein Bild erstmal beschreiben. Wie sieht das aus?
Also alle Codex, die wir heutzutage so haben für Video, basieren auf den gleichen mathematischen Prinzipien. Eigentlich sind das die DCT-Codex, diskrete Cosinostransformation. Das ist eine mathematische Abbildung, die ich verwenden kann, um solche Bilder darzustellen. Die Alternative dazu wären Wavelets. Die hat man im Moment noch nicht so wirklich in Benutzung, weil sie auch mehr Sprache brauchen. Das ist bei den Videos noch ein bisschen früh. Bei den Bildern ist man da schon weiter.
Die Wavelets brauchen mehr Speicher?
Nee, mehr Prozessor.
Ach so, aber sie sind ja eigentlich angetreten, um die... Richtig. Schaffen sie das auch?
Ja, wenn ich genügend CPU-Kraft habe, um das alles dann auch in Echtzeit bei Videos, das ist das Kritische, dann dekodieren zu können, dann ist das eine schöne Sache. Es gibt halt nichts anderes außer DCT und Wavelet. Das ist ja jedenfalls nichts, was mir bekannt wäre, was dann auch in diesen effizienten Sphären wäre, um da konkurrenzfähig zu sein. Und aus dieser DCT-Familie ist in witziger Weise die Algorithmen vom Prinzip her immer relativ ähnlich. Da sind halt dann andere Spezialfeatures dabei, um noch mehr rausdrehen zu können, um irgendwelche Parameter zu optimieren. Aber vom Grundprinzip sind sie eigentlich gar nicht mal so unterschiedlich. Also gerade diese, gut, DWXX wird jetzt ein bisschen ein schlechtes Beispiel, weil die sind dann sogar tatsächlich miteinander verwandt. Aber solche Windows-Media-Video-Codex oder MPEG-4-Codex, die sind nicht so unterschiedlich. Oder Sorensen-Codex. Das waren im Prinzip auch alles Sachen, die halt die aktuelle Forschung abgebildet hatten. Und das waren DCT-Codex.
Okay, dann bleiben wir erstmal bei denen. Also die sind sich alle sehr einig, aber sie unterscheiden sich dann letztlich im Detail.
Genau.
Aber die Detaile sind nicht ganz unwichtig, weil die Qualitätssteigerungen, die diese Codex in den letzten Jahren gehabt haben, sind ja nicht ganz unerheblich. Ist das im Wesentlichen jetzt auf diese B-Frames zurückzuführen?
Das ist ein großer Punkt, richtig. Also, ja, angefangen bei MPEG 1, was glaube ich nur iFrames hatte am Anfang, über MPEG 2, wo dann die P-Frames dazu kamen und MPEG 4 dann mit den B-Frames. Im Prinzip kann man so mehr oder weniger einen Timeline aufbauen. Es gibt dann noch andere Sachen, zum Beispiel Entropie-Kodierung. Da haben wir bei H264 nochmal einen Schritt nach vorne. Das ist dieses K-Pack, das hat man vielleicht schon mal gehört, als Option, was man mitgeben kann beim Kodieren.
Entropie-Encoding.
Ja, Entropie.
Da wird das K auskodiert.
C-A-B-A-C. Und wenn man das nicht hat, nennt sich glaube ich C-A-V-AL, glaube ich.
Ja, das war so. Die allwissenden Müllhalde meint, dass K-Pack steht für Context Adaptive Binary Arithmetic Coding. Das klingt schon nach was.
Ja, super, sehr beeindruckend.
Okay, und das wird jetzt neu verwendet sozusagen?
Ja, also das sind diese Sachen, die brauchen immer mehr Rechenzeit, können aber dann härter kompamieren. Das ist immer so der Trade-Off, den man halt machen muss bei solchen Sachen. Wie das im Detail funktioniert, das kann ich dir jetzt auch gar nicht so hundertprozentig erklären. Da hört es nämlich auf, das heißt, dreht mal weg.
Das ist auch was für die Mathematiker.
Genau, richtig. Aber ja, der Trade-Off ist halt der CPU-Zeit gegen Kompression.
Das heißt, das ist eigentlich der Trend. Man sagt sowieso auch, die Computer werden ja immer schneller, beziehungsweise viele dieser Funktionalitäten sind auch mittlerweile in Hardware gegossen. Grafikkarten kommen mit decoderfähiger CPU daher. Oder eben CPUs selber sind schon so schnell, dass sie sich einfach so ein bisschen das erlauben können, einfach mal die CPU-Zeit auf sowas wie Bildberechnung zu schmeißen. Und dadurch kann man halt jetzt immer bessere Bilder erzeugen, weil man vorher immer gesagt hat, das muss jetzt auch noch die langsamste Büchse. Irgendwie unser CD-Player hier, der kriegt jetzt wieder seine Video-CD rein und dann kriegt er da Bild für Bild und muss nur in der Lage sein, 25 Bilder pro Sekunde abzuspielen, zu dekodieren und dann war's das. Aber dadurch kann man halt bei Bewegungen nicht sehr viel Detailschärfe erzeugen. Mit der Datenmenge, die man dann dafür aufwendet. Und deswegen war die Qualität so niedrig.
Genau. Oder man hatte von vornherein nur 15 Bilder pro Sekunde, was auch lange Ursus war.
Ja, stimmt, genau, 15 Bilder. Stimmt.
Man fand sie schon richtig gut.
Und, okay. Und was sind denn jetzt, ich meine, jetzt gibt es ja noch ein paar andere Namen, um jetzt nochmal so kurz zu den Playern auf dem Feld zurückzukommen. Also neben QuickTime, das ist zum Beispiel schon mal so eine Sache, die viele Leute halt immer wieder missverstehen. Es wird dann immer von QuickTime-Filmen gesprochen. Ich frage die Leute, was ist denn das? Ja, das war QuickTime. Das beantwortet dann natürlich herzlich wenig, weil das eben nur der Container ist. Die Frage ist, was ist da drin? Das weiß man natürlich auch vorher nicht. Das sieht man ja auch nicht an der Dateiendung. So ein Punkt MOV oder auch ein Punkt AVI sagt halt nichts darüber aus. Also ist egal, ob man das jetzt mit Apple macht oder mit Microsoft macht. Wenn die Leute sagen, das ist ein AVI, dann sagt das ja auch nichts aus. Da kann ja auch alles Mögliche drin sein. Aber was sind denn so die wichtigsten Schritte gewesen? Also du hast vorhin dieses Indio, da habe ich dich überhaupt unterbrochen, das Indio entwickelt. Das war eigentlich das Erste, was so cross-Plattform halbwegs vertreten war, oder?
Ja, also bei Video, Cinepak, Indio, genau, das waren die ersten, die so...
Aber die benutzt ja heute kein Mensch mehr.
Nein, also nein. Heute, ja gut, was man heute benutzt...
Ich meine, was kam danach? Warum hat das keiner mehr benutzt? Also ich weiß, dass die Firma Sorensen, die kam dann irgendwann aufs Feld. Die hat ja dann diesen Sorensen-Codec, ich glaube, der hieß auch einfach nur so. Der war so ganz okay. Apple hat den erstmal groß befeiert und dann waren die irgendwie mit Apple auch ein bisschen verheiratet eine Weile. Oder wie lief das?
Ja genau, die hatten dann Exklusivverträge und Lizenzabkommen, um diese Sorensen-Codecs in QuickTime zu verwenden. Das ging eine ganze Weile lang so. Das waren Sorensen 2 und 3 damals. Das waren die State-of-the-Art-Codecs, die man in QuickTime benutzt hat. Auf der anderen Seite, was war auf der anderen Seite? Ich glaube, auf der anderen Seite kam lange Zeit nichts. Da war tatsächlich INDEO sehr lange in Verwendung. Dann kamen schon diese MPEG-Derivate. Microsoft Video, MPEG-4-Versionen, aus der dann DivX entstanden ist.
Ich glaube, das sind dann schon gleich darüber gegangen. Darauf wollte ich eigentlich mal zu sprechen kommen. Das ist ja so ein bisschen diese Geburtsstunde. Auch der Wahrnehmung von filmtauglichem Video. Also irgendwann kam dieses DivX auf. Und was ist DivX genau gewesen am Anfang?
Am Anfang war es tatsächlich einfach nur ein freigehackter Codec, den Microsoft veröffentlicht hatte. Ursprünglich nur als Codec, der in Streaming-Formaten benutzt werden sollte, in ASF. Und die DivX-Leute hatten das so freigepatcht. Was ist ASF? Das ist Active Streaming Format, glaube ich. Ja, genau, so müsste es gewesen sein. Das war deren Lösung, um zu konkurrieren gegen Reel Video, Reel Audio.
Ist das der Nachfolger von AVI?
Am letzten Ende ist es dann ja.
Okay, aber heute ist es ja Windows Media, heißt es heute.
Genau, der Titel hat es sich geändert. Also, vielleicht um die Nummer und Klartöne mal festzumachen, es gibt diese Frameworks, die in der Regel ein Paket aus Codecs, Containern unterstützen. Da hat man Video for Windows und später dann Windows Media auf der einen Seite. Man hat QuickTime, das ist also auch nicht streng genommen die Bezeichnung für das Format QuickTime.
Sondern für die gesamte Integration in dem Betriebssystem mit allem drum herum.
Genau, für das Framework. Und MOF ist nur der Container. Also es kann durchaus sein, dass jemand anders irgendwo nochmal ein MOF implementiert und alle Container unterstützt und alle Codecs unterstützt. Und das dann eben voll benutzen kann, aber es ist kein QuickTime. QuickTime ist dann auch nur ein Framework.
Okay, das heißt unter Windows hatten wir Video for Windows, dann Windows Media. Und dann haben sie AVI weggeschmissen und haben sich das ASF-Container-Format gemacht, weil das musste dann auch Streaming unterstützen und das konnte das alte AVI in dem Sinne nicht. Oder zumindest fehlten ihnen irgendwelche Features, sodass sie das gemacht haben. Und wie kam das dann mit diesem MPEG-4-Codec, der dann so komisch war? MPEG-4 war schon so in etwa publiziert?
Bei der MPEG laufen diese Standardisierungsverfahren alle immer sehr, sehr lange. Aus irgendeinem Grund, der mir nicht bekannt ist. Das geht ewig.
Die müssen sich alle einig sein.
Ja, also das scheint so. Und in der Zeit sind dann eben Leute auf den Markt gekommen, gerade bei Microsoft. Und Sorensen war glaube ich auch einer von diesen Vertretern. Die haben sich halt aktuelle Techniken genommen und gesagt, ja, das dauert uns alles zu lange. Wir möchten sowas gerne an den Markt bringen. Wir haben das dann getan.
Und was hat Microsoft dann da gemacht?
Die haben sich die MPEG-4-Specs angeschaut, Pi mal Daumen sowas in die Richtung implementiert und mal als Vorabversion verwendet. Das hieß, glaube ich, einfach MPEG-4-Vorabversion, nichts umzulernen. Also, die hatten das, glaube ich, auch durchaus so gemagelt.
Implementiert heißt, dass es dann bei Windows 95 oder so dabei war? Es lag dabei.
Das sind natürlich Details, die ich nicht weiß.
Wir fragen mal die alte wissende Milchheit. Fahr einfach fort.
Ja, dieser Code war einfach nicht schlecht. Das war einfach der Reiz an diesem Ding. Das war nicht schlecht und man wollte das haben. Und wie das so kommt, wenn man es nur stark genug haben möchte, irgendwann hat sich jemand erbarmt und diese Dinge befreit, so dass man mit diesem Codec auch Dateien codieren konnte, die auf der Platte lagen.
Was heißt denn befreit? Das heißt, es wurde tatsächlich dieser Codec, so wie er von Microsoft im Betriebssystem mitgeliefert wurde, diese Datei, wo der Code drin ist, der wurde dann benutzt von außen, ohne dass der Wasser wusste, von wem er benutzt wird.
Soweit ich weiß, ist es so gelaufen. Ich hatte damals kein Windows-PC, aber das ist das, was man so gesehen hatte. Die Leute haben es eben so weit freigepatcht, dass man es nicht nur benutzen konnte, um Live-Video zu dekodieren, sondern dass man auch Dateien lokal in dieses Format bringen konnte. Das war super. Das konnte man dann tauschen, uploaden und benutzen.
Und das hieß dann DIVX. Auf einmal brach die Hölle los. Das wurde dann ja auch in einen AVI-Container reingetan.
Richtig.
Aber warum hat man den dann nicht gleich ASF genommen, wenn das wieso dafür geschrieben war?
Das war damals, glaube ich, einfach von den Frameworks von Microsoft her nicht so vorgesehen, dass man das als Container benutzt hat für Stored-Videos. Sondern das war damals deren Live-Format.
Alles klar, verstehe. Und da war dann AVI das Einzige, was es eigentlich gab. Und dann hat man das genommen.
Genau, jeder konnte AVI sprechen.
Genau, gab es die schon massenhaft die Cola dafür. So, und dann war es in der Welt. Und dann wurde das sozusagen zur Basis des freien Filmerwerbs im Internet. Kann man so sagen.
Ja, über ein paar Ecken. Also da haben sich noch eine ganze Menge von Gruppen irgendwie nicht gekloppt. Aber es gab dann irgendwelche Forks von diesen ganzen Sachen. Dann sollte mal das Zeug teilweise Open Source werden. Das ist dann aber doch nicht geworden. Da gab es ein Projekt MAIO, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Dann gab es noch drei IVX, die auch noch eine Variante davon hatten, die dann auch auf dem Markt irgendwann lief. DIVIX als eigene Firma ist dann irgendwann auch noch in Erscheinung getreten, haben das Ganze dann kommerzialisiert noch dazu. Dann kam XWITZ, die diese Open Source Planungen, die es gegeben hat, und ich glaube teilweise auch wirklich mal released worden sind, wieder aufgegriffen hatten und das dann als XWITZ in Analogie zum DIVIX weiterentwickelt hatten. Die sind auch größtenteils kompatibel, da sie alle aus dieser gleichen Quelle rauskommen, aus diesem befreiten, einfach geschrieben, Codec von Microsoft, aber dann eben in den Daes dann doch wieder nicht ganz hundertprozentig.
Aber XWITZ erzeugt ja schon ein kompatibles MPEG-4.
Ja, ich glaube inzwischen sind die komplett kompatibel nach Speck. Also damals war einfach das Speck nun gar nicht komplett. Das waren halt Vorserien-Entwicklungen. Aber inzwischen, DIVX beispielsweise, ist meines Wissens fähig, komplett zu hundertprozentig kompatible Speckkonformen zu machen.
Also sowohl DIVX als auch XWITZ. Wobei DIVX als Firma jetzt vor kurzem ja auch dann sicher sein eigenes Containerformat gegönnt hat. Das sind dann diese Punkt-DIVX-Files, um halt da ihren online Video-Store und so weiter ein passendes Format zu liefern und nicht unbedingt AVI weiter verwenden zu müssen.
Ja, wobei ich glaube, dass dieses Punkt-DIVX gar nicht mal wirklich so ein richtig eigenes Format ist, sondern da hat man sich dann auch ein eigenes File-Ending besorgt, um dann zu zeigen, wenn das Dokument diese Datei-Endung hat, dann kann ich sichergehen, dass es alle DIVX-Erweiterungen kann und dass es auch irgendwelche AVI-Erweiterungen, Protokoll-Erweiterungen kann, um große Dateien zu schützen, die größer als 2 GB sind. Ich kann es nicht beschwören, aber ich glaube, das ist einfach nur eine Bezeichnung für einen erweiterten AVI-Container meines Wissens.
Ja, ich erwarte auch ehrlich gesagt nichts anderes. Wie ich ja schon in der Einführung ausgeführt hatte, kommen die ja eigentlich alle aus der gleichen Vergangenheit. Also da ist nicht sehr viel anders. Auch QuickTimeMov basiert auf demselben Prinzip wie die ganzen anderen EFF-Files. Das ist ein cooles Format. Also das ist echt toll. Der Unterschied zwischen dem, was Microsoft übernommen hat, haben sie natürlich eine Änderung gemacht. Also im Gegensatz zu allen anderen, sie haben natürlich die Bytes verdreht, weil sie natürlich auf ihrem Intel die Byte-Order anders hatten. Und deswegen sind die Riff-Files halt alle irgendwie verdreht und alle anderen machen es halt mit der normalen Byte-Order. Aber so ist das normal. So, und jetzt haben wir irgendwie, glaube ich, fast alles erwähnt. Jetzt gibt es aber natürlich noch ein Format, was derzeit extrem, wie soll ich sagen, nachdem Reel Audio eigentlich erstmal das Internet im Strom genommen hatte, also QuickTime hatte so diese kurze Hochzeit mit den CDs. Dann kam Reel Audio und hat dieses Streaming über das Internet populär gemacht. Dann kam halt DivX, was irgendwie AVI eine späte Wiederbelebung gebracht hat und was im Prinzip schon mal so die Vorarbeit war, dahingehend, dass man eigentlich das, was MPEG-4 als Standard an Video-Features definiert, dass das das ist, was man haben will. Auch wenn es erstmal noch nicht MPEG-4 war, aber heutzutage ist eben das, was sowohl bei DivX aus der Welt rausfällt, als auch bei dem X-Wid-Projekt, ist MPEG-4-kompatibeles Video. Zumindest sollte es das sein. Ob es das immer in einzelnen Fällen ist, weiß ich nicht. Und als Container-Format hat ja MPEG-4 auch ein eigenes im Angebot. Das MPEG-4 MP4-Format.
Genau, richtig.
Was wiederum auf QuickTime basiert.
Auf MOF zurückgeht, genau.
Auf MOF zurückgeht. Das heißt, auch das basiert wieder auf demselben Grundprinzip. Man hat irgendwann mal das QuickTime-MOF-Format genommen und hat gesagt, okay, das funktioniert so, das ist jetzt seit zehn Jahren in aktiver Benutzung und da sind irgendwie die wichtigen Features drin und die, die da nicht drin sind, die kriegen wir da jetzt noch mit rein. Und das ist dann sozusagen MPEG-4. Und damit ist irgendwie alles komplett. Und gab es dann noch irgendeinen großen Schub? RealAudio, DivX, dann war eigentlich erstmal eine ganze Weile lang Ruhe. Damit waren irgendwie alle glücklich. Und der nächste Schub war ja eigentlich der Video im Web. Und da kam dann ein alter Bekannter wieder zu neuen Ehren. Flash, was immer so ein bisschen so eine Nischenrolle gefüllt hat. Es war zwar sehr weit verbreitet, aber eigentlich wurde es für COM irgendwas anderes verwendet als für Werbung. Oder eben für irgendwelche Spiele oder sonstwiegen interaktiven Climbim-Künstler-Webseiten, die man nicht benutzen kann. Dafür war Flash immer super. Aber auf einmal machte das total Sinn, weil das jetzt eigentlich so der Pionier der Video-Widgets ist im Web. Auf einmal war es möglich, so wie man Bilder darstellen konnte, auch ein Video zu machen. Das hat ja das Web-Konsortium über Jahre nicht hinbekommen, da mal einen halbwegs brauchbaren Standard zu definieren. Und jetzt wurde so von hinten wieder das eingeführt. Was ist Flash-Video? Also es gibt ja diese FLV-Dateien, die dann letzten Endes in diesem Web-Plan abgespielt werden. Was steckt da drin?
Im Prinzip ist Flash eigentlich auch sogar wieder eine ganze Familie, ein ganzes Framework, in dem verschiedene Codec drin sein können. Also verschiedene Formate von Video drin sein können. Bei Video ist es zu Anfang mal der Sorensen Spark gewesen, was sich letzten Endes herausgestellt hat, als eine Variante von H263. Das ist auch ganz witzig, wenn man da mal anschaut und die Open-Source-Implementierungen beispielsweise bei FFmpeg sich ansieht. Das ist im Prinzip H263. Dann gibt es in Flash auch noch ein On-Tour-Codec. Ich glaube, VP6 ist es in dem Fall. Der kam allerdings relativ spät, also vor zwei, drei Jahren erst. Zwei Jahre, glaube ich, 2005. Und ganz aktuell haben sie auf der Flash-Plattform auch noch neu den H264. Aber das, was man normalerweise im Netz sieht, ist der Sorensen Spark, also H263.
Was ist das jetzt für eine Familie? Diese H-Punkt-Geschichten sieht man ja immer wieder. Ist das ein Ergebnis der... Also, wer hat das standardisiert? Also, das ist ein Standard, oder?
Ja, richtig.
Und wer hat das standardisiert?
Das kommt aus einer anderen Ecke, und zwar aus der ITU, International Telecommunications Union, also aus der Videotelefonie-Szene. Das sind die, die hatten H261, H263, H264. Was ursprünglich gedacht war für ISDN-Videotelefone, was man auch in den 90ern halbweise kannte und hatte und wusste, dass es die Zukunft und was nie gekommen ist.
Genau. ISDN, alles über ein Netz.
Ja, genau, richtig.
Jetzt morgen Bildtelefonie und keiner wollte es.
Die hatten sich in irgendeiner Aktion, die mir auch nicht näher bekannt ist, letzten Endes dann mal zusammengetan mit ihren Kollegen von der MPEG und gemeint, ja, wir haben da was, wollen wir das nicht irgendwie kombinieren. Und auf die Art und Weise ist dann der H264 als Part 10 Erweiterung, also Kapitel 10 in dem riesen MPEG-4 Gesamtwerk erschienen als Erweiterung, als weiterer Codec, den man in MPEG-4 benutzen kann. Das ist zurzeit auch state of the art.
Beziehungsweise auch bekannt unter dem Kürzel AVC, Advanced Video Codec, das ist sozusagen MPEG-4 Version 2.0, kann man eigentlich fast sagen. Oder wenn man das jetzt auf das Video bezieht? Sonst gibt es auch nur ein MPEG-Video-Codec.
Ja, richtig. Man kann aber unterscheiden. Und bei MPEG-4, also ok, im Prinzip hast du recht, es sind zwei Kapitel, die sich mit Video-Codecs beschäftigen in MPEG-4. Das ist einmal Part 2, einmal Part 10. Also Part 2 und Part 10. Dann musst du auch Teil sagen.
Ok, Teil 2, Teil 10 oder Part 2, Part 10. Wir verstehen das.
Im Teil 2 gibt es aber schon mehrere, also zwei Varianten. Uns mal den Simple Profile und den Advanced Simple Profile. Im Advanced Simple Profile tauchen dann diese Beam Frames beispielsweise auf, die es im Simple Profile nicht gibt. Also man kann da schon im Prinzip zwei Varianten unterscheiden. Das ist dann deswegen lange relevant gewesen für Leute wie mich, die Sachen im Internet veröffentlicht hatten, weil QuickTime nur Simple Profile konnte.
Also MPEG-4, der gesamte Standard, alles, was mit Audio und Video zu tun hat und einschließlich des Containerfiles. Definiert Audio-Codecs, definiert Video-Codecs, derer mittlerweile zwei. Und jeder Codec, jeder Video-Codec hat dann noch verschiedene Ausprägungen, sozusagen wie komplex er sein kann. Und das ist dann in Profilen festgehalten.
Profile und Level, genau.
Profile und Level. Okay, was macht das Profil und was macht ein Level?
Ein Profil vereinfacht gesagt spezifiziert die Features, also die Funktionen, die Fähigkeiten, die verwendet werden in diesem Codec. Und ein Profil zeigt an, wie stark der Coder ist, das Gerät ist, was dann dieses Format abspielen kann. Zum Beispiel, also ich kenne jetzt im Moment aktuell am besten eben den H264. Im H264 gibt es einen Baseline-Profile, einen Main-Profile und einen Extended-Profile.
Und Baseline-Profile ist sozusagen das Minimum.
Genau, Baseline ist für kleine iPods, Handys, Handheld-Media-Player gedacht und so weiter und so fort. Main ist gedacht für alles, was so durchschnittlich auf dem Markt sein sollte, von irgendwelchen Setup-Boxen, Computern, was man so kennt.
Und so Extended ist dann für High-End.
Genau, da sind dann irgendwelche größeren Video-Farbformate mit drin. Ich glaube hauptsächlich die Farbformate sind bei Extended noch mit mehr dabei. Also das sind die Features, also die Funktionen auf der einen Seite und die Level auf der anderen Seite. Als konkretes Beispiel, der iPod war lange Zeit Level 1.3. Das war eben eine Angabe, wie viel Bitrate dieser Player verträgt. Wenn ich 10 Megabit pro Sekunde entgegenwerfe, sträckt einfach der kleine Prozessor seine Waffen und kommt nicht mehr hinterher. Das heißt, er kann beispielsweise nur bis maximal 1 MBit, konnte er maximal dekodieren in Echtzeit, was man in Echtzeit machen muss, weil sonst hätte ich ja kein Video, das ich mir angucken kann. Und es geht dann rauf, Level 3 ist aktuell gerade bei den größeren iPods unterstützt. Das richtet sich in der Regel danach, was zur Zeit von den diversen Firmen an Hardware-Beschleunigungen auf dem Markt ist. Das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie die Einteilung willkürlich, sondern man guckt halt, ich habe so und so viel Strom, den ich verbrauchen möchte, ich kann diese Features relativ gut in Hardware umsetzen und dann unterstütze ich eben in den verschiedenen Profilen oder in verschiedenen Leveln die und die Fähigkeiten.
Aber das ist dann aber auch wohl definiert. Also das hängt dann alles in diesem mp4-Standard. Das heißt, man kann sich dann für sein Gerät, wenn man eins baut, einfach mal rausgucken, was könnte das Ding so leisten. Und dann sagt man dann einfach in der Dokumentation, ich kann das und das Profil mit dem und dem Level, und der Level definiert im Prinzip die Bitrate oder letzten Endes natürlich auch die Auflösung, weil die hängt da ja mit dran zusammen mit der Codierung. Und das Profil sagt halt generell erstmal, was für Features sind. Also kann ich die und die Frames, es gibt ja 1000 Features gibt es nicht, aber es gibt auf jeden Fall verdammt viele unterschiedliche Features. Ich habe mir die Liste irgendwann mal angeschaut und dann fing mein Kopf irgendwann an zu klingen. Dann habe ich es wieder sein gelassen. Also es ist auf jeden Fall krasses Zeug. Okay, ich spur mal kurz zurück. Man muss ja immer die Klammer wieder schließen, die man mal aufgemacht hat. Wir waren ja gerade bei Flash hängen geblieben. In dem Zusammenhang finde ich das nochmal ganz interessant. Also der Flash-Codec, der, den man jetzt meistens eigentlich sieht, ist eine Entwicklung von Sorensen, heißt Spark. Und ist aber letzten Endes nichts anderes als so ein Feature-Set, wie das im H263 von der ITU definierte Codec festgelegt hat. Da das nicht toll ist, haben sie sich irgendwann mal gedacht, da holen wir uns noch was Tolleres. Und dann sind sie bei O2-Shoppen gegangen und haben sich diesen VP6-Codec gekauft. Aber den benutzt eigentlich kein Mensch, weil man benutzt Flash irgendwie mit maximaler Kompatibilitätsbreite. Und dann nimmt man halt einfach das andere. Und YouTube hat ja auch schon gezeigt, it's good enough, it's good enough für Video überhaupt erst mal gucken. Und die Leute scheißen auf Qualität, wenn sie es dafür irgendwie sofort kriegen, was bemerkenswert ist. Aber jetzt seit Kurzem, finde ich einen relativ bemerkenswerten Schritt, gehen sie jetzt auch auf H264, also genau auf diesen Advanced-Video-Codec, der bei Impact 4 in Teil 10 oder Part 10, wie immer man möchte, festgeschrieben ist, und gehen sozusagen einen relativ großen Schritt, was Qualität betrifft, im Web nach vorne. Das ist dieses Flash 9, richtig?
Richtig.
Und ja, hier auf unsere tollen Shiny Apple Books, wurde das ja vor Kurzem auch per Software-Update breit drauf gestreut. Bleibt natürlich die Frage, wie lange das dauert, bis sich so eine neue Version von Flash im Internet wirklich verbreitet. Aber spätestens, wenn das der Fall ist, davon kann man vielleicht mal ausgehen, in so einem Jahr, bedeutet das ja eigentlich, dass so die Hegemonie von H264 sichergestellt ist? Oder sehe ich das falsch?
Das siehst du mal und sagst, das ist noch genau richtig. Also ich denke, Flash hat da gewonnen mit dem H264.
Flash hat gewonnen oder H264 hat gewonnen? Das ist ja die Frage. Wir hatten da jetzt klein beigegeben. Also gewinnt Flash, weil sie jetzt auch diesen Standard unterstützen oder gewinnt der Standard, weil Flash das jetzt auch unterstützt?
Ja.
Sowohl als auch.
Man möchte in den nächsten Jahren einfach in dieser HD-Welle mitspimmen, die wir jetzt haben. Und man braucht, um HD übers Netz übertragen zu können, irgendeine Form von Codec, der wirklich ein bisschen mehr bringt als dieses H263, was wir bisher hatten. Und bei ON2, da könnte man sich vielleicht streiten, ob sie mit ON2 VP7 vielleicht auch eine Option gehabt hätten, da was zu machen. Aber das mit H264, das scheint sich einfach so am Markt durchzusetzen, dass man nach gutem Gewissens sagen kann, wenn ein paar Schlüsselfiguren das jetzt so unterstützen, wie eben QuickTime und Flash, dann ist da eigentlich nicht mehr groß ein Weg dran vorbei.
Aber wer treibt den H264 sonst noch? Also ich meine, Apple hat es natürlich großräumig unterstützt, dadurch, dass sie es eben in QuickTime eingebaut haben und vor allem in den iPods. Alle iPod-Videos konnten, also alle Video-Ipods konnten von vornherein dieses H264 abspielen, natürlich auch nur bis zu bestimmten Level und Profile und so weiter. Das war auch relativ eingeschränkt. Aber grundsätzlich sind sie schon mal auf diesen Codec gegangen. Und wer macht es sonst noch? Microsoft macht es nicht.
DVDs, sowohl Blu-ray als auch HD-DVD, spezifiziert komplett den H264 rein.
Aber beide haben auch die Microsoft-Nachgeburt, weil die müssen wir ja endlich noch erwähnen als letzte Entwicklung. Also Microsoft hat sich ja nicht wirklich geschlagen gegeben und haben dieses Windows-Video, also Windows Media Video WMV rausgebracht. Und man kann sich darüber streiten, wie erfolgreich das jetzt war. Zumindest den Podcasting war, haben sie definitiv verloren, weil sie irgendwie weder einen Player noch Plan hatten. Aber was einfach dazu geführt hat, dass eben sehr viel Video schon H264 war. Aber sie versuchen halt hintenrum, dadurch, dass sie das jetzt standardisiert haben als VC1 und auf HD-DVD gesetzt haben, versuchen sie das halt irgendwie zu etablieren.
Ach, etablieren, das ist kein Problem. Das ist die Frage, ob es wirklich dominant wird. Und dieser Kelch scheint wohl an uns rüber zu gehen. Ich meine, es ist jetzt gefährlich, so was zu sagen hier in einem Podcast, der nachher archiviert wird und dann in X-Jahren irgendwases nochmal an. Und dann wissen wir es genau. Aber so wie es jetzt zur Zeit aussieht, ich meine, sie haben halt ihre Klientel und die ist glücklich und das ist alles wunderbar. Also mit Flash, was ja durchaus sehr weit deployed ist. Adobe strengt sich jetzt auch gerade an, mächtig das auch zu deployen, dass es in den Markt kommt. Es kam vor ein paar Tagen jetzt eine ganze Reihe von Security-Advisories, von Warnungen von Adobe, unsere Flash-Player in den alten Versionen enthalten diese und diese und diese Bugs. Ihr solltet dringend updaten. Und als Nettonebeneffekt hat dann die Installed Base auch diesen H264-Support. Und dann kann man damit arbeiten.
Ja gut, aber das bezieht sich ja, Flash hat ja eigentlich nur eine Dominanz im Web. So, und Web-Video mag ja relativ wichtig sein, aber die Leute sind ja, wie wir sehen, auch mit dem alten Kram noch relativ glücklich. Und jetzt für HD, ich meine, letzten Endes machen wir uns nichts vor. Am meisten wird halt einfach konsumiert über Download im Netz und die wenigsten davon sind legal. So, und da dominiert ja derzeit eigentlich noch MPEG-4. Also das normale Part 2 MPEG-4, das ist mal so.
Genau.
In diesem komischen AV-Format, muss man dazu sagen.
Ja, das stimmt, ja. In der Regel irgendwelche X-Width-Video in AV-Containern und manchmal sogar noch mit MPEG-1, Layer-3, Audio-Spur dazu. Also ein richtig schöner Bachtat als Flickwerk zwischen allen möglichen Codex aus irgendwelchen Familien und irgendwoher. Das stimmt, richtig. Und es ist sogar so, dass teilweise die Standalone-Player, also DVD-Player, die auch Video-Codes abspielen können, speziell dieses Marktsegment sogar anspricht und dann auch Support gibt für solche Formate. ABI-Container mit MPEG-1, L3 Audio und MPEG-4 Advanced Simple Profile Video. Das wird uns auch noch eine ganze Weile erhalten bleiben. Und das wird auch Flash mit H263, bzw. Sonsens Spark, uns noch eine ganze Weile erhalten bleiben. Erstens, weil es den Leuten offensichtlich gut genug ist. Und zweitens, weil es schlicht auch weniger Ressourcen braucht als so ein ganz, ganz moderner HD-Codec. Also ja, es ist leider gut genug. Relativ leider. Also es spürt einen natürlich ein bisschen als Kompressionist, wenn man weiß, es gibt diese und jene Formate, wo man noch ein paar Prozent mehr Effizienz rausziehen könnte. Aber na ja, wenn es die Leute halt wollen. Es ist bei den Audiokodecs sogar noch schlimmer. Bei Audiokodecs haben wir ja seit Jahren MP3. MP3, genau. Und seit auch schon Jahren haben wir AAC und Warbis. Und ja, das sind die beiden großen Formate. Aber MP3 ist gut genug.
Okay, ja, zur Audio kommen wir ja gleich noch. Und wir sollten auch noch mal ein bisschen was zu Tools sagen. Aber da wir jetzt so wild in diese Videowelt eingestiegen sind, bleiben wir vielleicht noch mal kurz dabei. Also wie das mit der H264 weitergeht, das werden wir dann sehen. Ich persönlich muss sagen, ich mache ja bei Chaosradio, also bei ChaosTV im Kanal auch H264. Es ist einfach, es sieht gut aus. Und es gibt die Werkzeuge mittlerweile dafür, um das Ganze auch zu erzeugen. Und vor allem gibt es auch relativ, also wir haben hier keinerlei Berichte von Inkompatibilitäten. Ich kann mich zumindest an keine erinnern. Das finde ich ja schon mal ziemlich gut. Und es wird auch langsam mal Zeit, dass man sich da einigt. Jetzt gibt es ja auch noch ein paar andere Player, die man jetzt vielleicht noch erwähnen muss. Meine Liste ist irgendwie endlos, aber was mir jetzt noch einfällt, ist natürlich, dass wir so den klassischen Videobereich vielleicht mal noch mal kurz beleuchten sollten, nämlich Fernsehen. Auch da gab es ja so einen digitalen Schub. Und da möchte man ja auch noch weiter. Stichwort ist DVB, also Digital Video Broadcasting, in seinen ganzen verschiedenen Ausprägungen. Es gibt da, soweit ich weiß, im Wesentlichen vier. Also halt DVB, dann kommt dann so ein Buchstabe, da gibt es dann T für das terrestrische Ausstrahlen, was ja jetzt so schrittweise über Deutschland abgelassen wird. Ich weiß nicht, ist das hier in Ulm auch schon Standard? DVB-S kommt vom Satelliten, DVB-C kommt aus einem Kabel. Und alle diese drei, einen habe ich jetzt noch bewusst ausgelassen, sind ja auf dem MPEG-2-Standard, der Weiterentwicklung von MPEG-1, MPEG-3, wie du dich gerade so schön versprochen hast, gibt es ja nicht, weil alle dann wohl zu Recht das immer verwechselt hätten mit MP3, was nicht MPEG-3 ist, sondern MP3 ist. Und von daher war es, glaube ich, ganz klug, gleich auf die 4 zu gehen. So, jetzt ist das alles MPEG-2 und das ist natürlich relativ alt und relativ bandbreitenfressend. Das ist also gemacht worden für etwas, wo man viel Platz hat. Ein Kabel, wo man halt gedacht hat, 10 Fernsehsender, das muss doch reichen, vielleicht sind es 20 oder 30, je nachdem. Man hat gemerkt, es gibt eigentlich sehr viel mehr Bedarf, man kann eigentlich gar nicht genug Kanäle haben. Dementsprechend wird Kabel den Bedarf auch nicht abdecken können, sondern letzten Endes natürlich nur das Internet, wie das eben so ist. Oder eben Satelliten, da geht es ganz einfach. Da schießt man noch einen hoch und sucht ihn in eine neue Frequenz usw. Da kann man sich das alles leisten. Und jetzt ist der vierte Buchstabe im Gespräch, das DVB-H. Ich weiß nicht, warum sie da H genommen haben, wirklich jetzt für Handy. Handheld, okay. Hier geht es um sozusagen mobiles TV. Ich verfolge diese Diskussion schon seit einiger Zeit und bin ja kein großer Freund vom Fernsehen. Ich schaue keins und ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, dass Handheld TV wirklich irgendeinen nennenswerten Markt hat. Aber sie boxen sich ganz ordentlich und offensichtlich scheinen sie jetzt auch eingesehen zu haben, dass sie da mit MPEG 2 nicht weiterkommen. Sondern DVB-H ist im Wesentlichen auch dieses H264, oder?
Ich glaube, DVB-H ist H264 und DVB-S2 haben sie auch spezifiziert. Da haben sie nachträglich noch H264 reingepackt.
So was gibt es auch noch.
Um mehr Kanäle über die gleiche Bandbreite zu kriegen. Das ist wieder der gleiche Punkt. MPEG 2, wenn man ihm genügend Bandbreite gibt, genügend Bitrate gibt, kriegt man mit MPEG 2 auch gute Qualität hin. Man braucht halt mehr Bitrate. Das heißt, das große Argument für MPEG 4 oder H264 ist, in der gleichen Bandbreite mehr Content unterzubringen.
Achso, wir haben noch eine andere Anwendung von MPEG 2 vergessen, die auch sehr populär ist.
DVDs.
DVDs, genau. Das ist ja eigentlich auch so die Quelle, wo derzeit das ganze Videomaterial herkommt. Da kann man ja sehr schön sehen, wie sich die Generationen da auch unterscheiden. Vorher hatten wir so einen 9 GB DVD, und am Ende kriegt man heutzutage mit dem H264, der ordentlich eingestellt ist. Wie klein kriegt man das, damit es noch eine ordentliche Qualität hat? Hast du das mal ausprobiert? 500, 600 MB?
Um was zu machen?
Um eine normale DVD. Also eine normale Länge ist jetzt so, was weiß ich, 90 Minuten Film.
27,76 von der Auflösung her. Ja, wenn man sich anstrengend guckt, guckt man es auf eine CD runter, ja. Man merkt dann schon, dass es komplimiert ist, aber das ist auch geschehenreichend gut. Also das passt.
So, auf irgendwas wollte ich jetzt gerade noch hinaus mit den Videos. Was hatten wir denn jetzt gerade? Flash, DVB. Also das ist jetzt eigentlich so das, wo sich die Videowelt drin bewegt. Also es gibt halt die ITU und MPEG haben sich irgendwie geeinigt. Und es sieht so aus, als ob die anderen Player, also Apple und Adobe, dem da sozusagen folgen. Und der einzige, der noch einen anderen Weg geht, ist derzeit Microsoft.
Es gibt noch eine andere Schiene. Also es kristallisiert sich mehr oder weniger raus, dass wir die Windows-Schiene bekommen, mit Microsoft und der Windows-Media-Architektur, dass wir eine Free-Schiene bekommen, eine Linux-Schiene bekommen, mit Ok. Die haben auch als Familie mehrere Codecs, Okteora, Okvobis. Ich glaube Dirac wird zurzeit dann gearbeitet, das in Ok reinzubekommen. Und dann MPEG-4, genau. Also diese drei Schienen scheinen sich im Moment rauszukristallisieren. Bei Flash wusste man lange Zeit nicht genau, wie das läuft. Aber nachdem die jetzt in MPEG-4 eingeschwungen sind, ist es im Prinzip Windows, Linux und der Rest der Welt, was dann Standalone Player betrifft und DVB betrifft und Apple betrifft.
Die freie Welt wollte ich jetzt auch nicht rauslassen, sondern die wollte ich jetzt sozusagen nachschieben. Vielleicht kannst du ja mal kurz skizzieren, wie da eigentlich so der Ist-Zustand ist. Also was also frei heißt, das Problem mit diesen ganzen anderen Standards ist natürlich, da haben viele Firmen entwickelt, viele Wissenschaftler waren da am Start, die haben sich alle kluge Sachen einfallen lassen, und wie das so ist, sie haben Patente da drauf. Und es ist natürlich ein Patent etwas, was einen allgemein verweltbaren Standard im Wesentlichen behindert. Deswegen haben die sich insbesondere bei MPEG 4 extrem Mühe gegeben, auch da sozusagen die Patentfrage von vornherein zu klären. Das heißt, es gibt Lizenzkosten, die sind damit im Wesentlichen abgedeckt, dass die ganzen Wissenschaftler da mal drüber nachgedacht haben. Es gibt allerdings, soweit ich weiß, auch lizenzfreie oder patentfreie Subversion, also das Baseline-Profile zum Beispiel. Das ist ein Profil, was nicht nur für kleine Player ist, sondern was auch versucht, teure Extra-Features rauszulassen. So stand es zumindest in der Beschreibung. Ich kann es nicht im Einzelnen genau sagen, worauf dann verzichtet werden musste. Aber so richtig frei im Sinne von freier Liebe ist es halt nicht. Und was bietet denn die Open Source und freie Software-Szene derzeit an Videolösungen und an Containern an?
Also Video und Container für Delivery-Formate, das sind ja die Formate, von denen wir jetzt reden, die beim End-User ankommen. Da gibt es primär die OK-Familie. Ich glaube, was anderes ist mir da gar nicht bekannt. Es gibt noch zwei, drei andere kleinere Sachen, die sich zum Beispiel um Lossless-Encoding von Audio kümmern. Aber so eine Multimedia-Plattform ist in der freien Szene halt OK etabliert. Da gibt es im Prinzip einen kompletten Stack an Protokollen. Angefangen von einem Transport-Stream, der definiert ist, das ist der OK. Wirklich von Container zu reden, ist da ein bisschen übertrieben. Da gibt es ein paar Projekte, die versuchen auch, ein mächtigeres Container-Format zu definieren.
Warum ist das übertrieben?
Weil das im Prinzip ähnlich wie bei MP3, einfach nur ein Bitstream ist und fertig, hat vorne ein bisschen Herder dran und das war's dann. Dann läuft das halt durch und dann hat man das.
Das heißt, man kann da nicht Probleme mit mehreren Audio-Spuren reinkriegen?
Zum Beispiel. Ich finde ja diese Container ganz spannend. Es gibt solche Features, um in verschiedenen Teilstücken eines Films verschiedene Frame-Raten zu fahren. So etwas kann zum Beispiel in Container-Signalisieren, dass in einem bestimmten Teil andere Settings herrschen. Das könnte man vielleicht sogar noch mit Headern machen, wenn man zwischendurch noch mal ein Header-Segment einfügt.
Verstehe, das heißt, wenn man erst ein normales Video, also so richtig gefilmtes Material, und dann hat man so ein bisschen Animation, wo man das irgendwie nicht braucht, dass man dann eine andere Frame-Rate macht, sowas?
Zum Beispiel genau, sowas kaum machen.
Aber das macht man eigentlich kaum, oder?
Sieht man sehr selten, nee. Also so einen Container haben sie nicht, arbeiten aber dran. Besonders gibt es da die Matroshka-Leute, die gehören jetzt nicht im engeren Sinne zu dieser OX-Szene dazu. Bei OX müsste man vielleicht dazu sagen, dass sich die Firma Xif, Firma Foundation, ich glaube das ist eine Firma, sich darum kümmert, hier das Vermarkt ein bisschen zu betreuen und als zentrale Anlaufstelle zu dienen, um beispielsweise halt, ja, was man so braucht, eben VCCs zu definieren, solche Geschichten, oder offizielle Referenzimplementierungen zu machen. Die Matroshka-Leute gehören da nicht dazu. Sind aber, glaube ich, mit der Intention durchaus starkgegangen, ein Container-Format zu bringen, um beispielsweise Wobis und Thora zu verpacken. Und dann solche Sachen wie Subtitles, also Untertitel mitzubringen, oder verschiedene Spur-Spuren, also Audispuren in verschiedenen Sprachen mitzubringen. Und sind auch halbwegs erfolgreich, aber eben nicht offiziell abgesignet von diesen XIF-Leuten, aus welchem Grund auch immer. Also es gab da noch OGM-Vorschläge als Org-Media-Container-Format. Und ich glaube aktuell gibt es ein Projekt Org Skeleton, wo sie wieder versuchen, ein sinnvolles Container-Format zu machen. Aber es ist nichts in Richtung etabliert, außer vielleicht Matroshka in offizieller Weise. Dann Video-Codex haben sie. Teora, das ist eine lustige Geschichte. Teora, das ist eigentlich eine Spende sozusagen, eine geistige Eigentumsspende von Ontu. Die hatten wir jetzt schon mal kurz erwähnt bei Flash. Die hatten ihren Ontu VP6 lizenziert an Flash. Und Ontu VP3 haben sie gespendet an Xif, um ihn zu verwenden als freien Video-Codex. Mehr oder weniger als, ja, ich würde mal denken, dass das eine Art Werbeaktion war von Ontu. Und ist auch tatsächlich dann genommen worden als das Teora-Format. Die hatten damals auch noch eine Eigenentwicklung. Das war der Octalkin, ist dann aber komplett eingeschlafen, weil mit dem Teora hatten sie dann einfach einen Codex, der schon funktioniert hat und der war auch nicht schlecht. Und die Theorie ist halt bei dem Ontu VP3, bzw. bei dem Teora, dass er hinreichend anders funktioniert als so ein klassischer MPEG-Video-Codec, dass er nicht von diesen Patenten betroffen sein müsste. Voraussichtlich, hoffentlich. So ganz unbeurteilig sicher sein kann man sich natürlich nicht, weil Software-Patente haben halt dieses Problem, dass man nie wirklich ausschließen kann, ob das nicht vielleicht doch irgendwo noch ein Patent auf eine Technik zutrifft, die ich da verwende. Das ist alles bei diesen mathematischen, bei den mathematischen, algorithmischen Patenten halt immer ein Riesenproblem. Aber die Vermutung ist halt in die Richtung, also man weiß nicht, dass es irgendwie was verletzen würde. Und es hätte theoretisch auch ON2 schon mal irgendwo herkriegen können müssen, da sie diesen Codec ja auch kommerziell lizenziert haben und rausgegeben haben. Ich glaube, ON2 ist zurzeit hauptsächlich in Skype, meines Wissens, in Verwendung. Der Videocodec von Skype für Videoconferencing ist, glaube ich, irgendeine Variante von ON2, VP6 oder so was, VP7 vielleicht. Also das ist einfach eine Firma, die lizenziert ein Codex. Und haben einen alten Codex, den sie noch rumliegen hatten, freigegeben mit dem Versprechen, okay, wir halten da eine ganze Reihe von Patenten. Also diese Theorie ist nicht patentfrei, wie es oft so schön heißt, sondern es sind halt Patente da, von denen aber ON2 versprochen hat, niemals jemanden irgendwie zu verklagen. Ich glaube, sie haben sogar einen Vertrag irgendwie geschlossen mit XIF, um das auch rechtlich bindend zu versprechen, dass sie da niemanden verklagen werden.
Okay, aber das sind Patente, die ON2 hält.
Richtig, genau.
Und nicht irgendwelche anderen. Also es kann auch durchaus noch sein, dass sozusagen jemand anders...
Ja, wer weiß. Also wir hatten, glaube ich, bei JPEG vor ein paar Jahren jemanden, der irgendwie plötzlich aufgetaucht ist und gemeint hat, ja, übrigens, JPEG benutzte was, was ich mir in den 80ern auch hab patentieren lassen. Und sie haben, glaube ich, sogar im Palletaufgleich verklagen können und dann Lizenzzahlungen bekommen. Oder bei MPEG 3 war das, glaube ich, sogar der Fall, dass mal zwischendurch jemand kam und gesagt hat, ja, übrigens, ich glaube, mein Patent hier könnte auch hier Anwendung finden. Also hätte ich gern auch Lizenzgebühren für die Verwendung von MPEG 3.
Ja, diese Patentfrage, das ist auch etwas, was viele treibt. Teora als freies Video-Codec, sag ich mal, ist ja eigentlich so featuremäßig. Also kann er das so mit dem H264 denn aufnehmen?
Also mit dem H264 nicht. Aber ich finde Teora eigentlich gar nicht mal so sehr schlecht. Ich finde, in meinen Tests schlägt sich Teora ungefähr auf dem Level von knapp unter MPEG für Simple Profile, ungefähr vielleicht mal mit MPEG für Simple Profile. Also zum Beispiel der Encoder von QuickTime für MPEG für Simple Profile, der war nicht unbedingt der beste Encoder für MPEG für Simple Profile. Da kann Teora mithalten eigentlich meines Erachtens nach. Gegen einen richtig guten Encoder kann es vielleicht nicht mithalten, aber da könnte man sich auch mal fragen, ob vielleicht ein besserer Encoder für das Teora-Format denkbar wäre, um da noch mal mehr auszukitzeln. Also bei diesen Formaten hängt es auch an Analysefähigkeiten von einem Encoder, dass der wirklich alles rausholen kann aus einem Format, was theoretisch denkbar ist. Ja, aktuell gab es eine Kritik von...
Aber B-Frames macht er nicht, ne?
Nein, sowas kann er beispielsweise nicht. Er hat auch diesen Backfield-Simple-Profile-Encoder von QuickTime nie gemacht, meines Wissens. Deswegen...
War er nicht so gut, obwohl das Feature sozusagen möglich gewesen wäre, haben sie es einfach nicht benutzt.
Richtig, genau. Ich würde ihn nicht so schlecht sehen auf Ebene von H261, was vor Kurzem aktuell mal gekommen ist. Da hatte ein Vertreter von Nokia bei der WhatWG oder ich glaube W3C sogar schon.
Bei W3C, die Diskussion wollte ich gerade ansprechen.
Da kam die Kritik, dass Teora von der Technik her nicht wirklich gut ist. Sie hatten das ungefähr verglichen mit H261. Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen nicht so ganz nett, aber ein bisschen besser finde ich den Codec schon.
Auch besser als H263?
Auf dem Niveau. Zwischen H263 und MP4 Simple Profile würde ich es ansiedeln, je nachdem was dann aus dem Encoder noch rauszuholen ist. Da würde ich es ungefähr ansiedeln. Es hat auch teilweise andere Eigenschaften in der Skalierung. Zum Beispiel bei MP4 sieht man sehr gerne Blockiness, also kleine Klötzchenbildungen, wenn man hart komprimiert. Das kennt man von JPEG auch. Da haben sie auch diese Klötzchenbildungen, wenn man hart komprimiert. Bei Teorolöffels sind sie ein bisschen anders. Da wird dann das Bild eher verwaschen. Man hat da keine Klötzchen, die irgendwie auffällig Kanten im Bild erzeugen, sondern es wird immer unschärfer und unschärfer. Das empfinden viele als angenehmer in der Eskalierung.
Würde ich auch sagen.
Ja, das finde ich eigentlich auch. Also ich finde ihn gar nicht so sehr schlecht. Aber das Argument kam eben von Nokia. Es ist zum einen mal technisch eben nicht so toll. Und das andere Argument war, dass man ja nicht wisse, ob da wirklich diese Patentfreiheit so gegeben ist, wie man das vermutet.
Und bei MPEG 4 und seinen Standards hat man das Gefühl, dass das Feld zumindest so weit bereinigt oder geschützt ist, dass sich so viele Leute darauf geeinigt haben, dass man jetzt hier in dem Kontext nicht weiter gegeneinander klagt, sondern dass der Blick auf die Patente, so wie er heute herrscht, eigentlich auch der gültige ist und dass daran nicht mehr gerüttelt wird.
Genau, man hat das Gefühl. Das sagst du genau richtig. Also es gibt von den MPEG-Leuten kein Versprechen, dass die Lizenzierung dieses MPEG-4-Hin-und-Her-Pakets, also da gibt es dann Lizenzabkommen für H264, für MPEG-4 Part 2, also den normalen MPEG-4. Für den Container kann man auch extra Lizenzen zahlen. Man kann extra Lizenzen zahlen für den Audiokodik, für ARC. Aber bei allen diesen Lizenzen, das sind jeweils dann ganze Konsortien, die dahinterstehen, bestehend aus diesen ganzen Leuten, die während der Entwicklung Forscher-Teams daran mitarbeiten hatten. Auch diese versprechen nicht, dass man damit durch ist, dass man eine Aliat-Elementen-Patente hat, weil es eben aus der Natur der Software-Patente her nicht so vertretbar ist, das zu sagen, okay, jetzt ist Schluss. Aber dadurch, dass die Big-Player da alle drin sind, ist es sehr, sehr wahrscheinlich, dass man da guten Gewissens hingehen kann und sagt, okay, jetzt ist dann gut, und da hat man die Lizenzen gezahlt und fertig. Die Einzigen, die meines Wissens wirklich diese ominöse Patent-Indemnification anbieten, ist nämlich Microsoft. Die versprechen, wenn irgendwas passiert, wir geben dir Schutz.
Die müssen erst mal durch uns durch, sozusagen.
Richtig.
Die halten sich da sozusagen auch für... Ich glaube, wenn sie das nicht tun würden, dann hätten sie da auch gar keine Chance.
Ja, anzunehmen. Also lustigerweise wird auch der VC1-Patentpool von der MPEG Licensing Association verwaltet. Also wenn man VC1 lizenzieren möchte, dann geht man zu MPEG LA.
Zu den Lizenzen möchte ich da nochmal kommen. Vielleicht nochmal abschließen zu Teora. Ich meine, wenn Teora qualitativ mit dem, was YouTube groß gemacht hat, mithalten kann, dann kann man ja nicht behaupten, dass es als Web- und Mindest-Video-Standard nicht vielleicht auch taugen würde. Ich finde diese Diskussion ganz interessant. Das W3C, mit dem sich da Nokia ein bisschen in die Haare bekommen hat, die sind zwar ein bisschen langsam, aber zumindest haben sie jetzt gesehen, dass man eben für den neuen HTML5-Standard ist es einfach zwingend erforderlich, dass mal das Problem Video erschlagen wird. Also auch Audio, weil weder Audio noch Video ist in HTML in irgendeiner Form wiedergegeben und es ist einfach nicht mehr zeitgemäß, weil das Web ist voll mit Audio und Video und man hat einfach den Bedarf. Gleiches Problem habe ich jetzt hier bei Chaosradio in den Webseiten. Würde ich natürlich auch gerne die Videos mal direkt anzeigen, aber ich habe mich bisher so rein mental noch nicht wirklich auf Flash so einigen können. Und wäre froh, wenn ich da nochmal drum herum kommen würde. Wenn es eben in irgendeiner Form standardisierten Weg geben würde, das zu tun. Und was wollte ich sagen? Ja genau, und Teora sozusagen als relativ freies System, als Minimum für das Web zu definieren, wäre natürlich schon ein interessanter Schritt. Also allein, um da so ein bisschen mehr Awareness auch für zu schaffen. Andererseits sehe ich halt auch, dass die Zahl der verfügbaren Tools relativ gering ist, um Teora zu erzeugen. Also die einzige, wenn gleich auch schon recht elegante Möglichkeit, die ich so kenne, sind von Xif diese Components, die für QuickTime bereitgestellt werden. Die schmeißt man sich einfach in einen Ordner. Und schon kann man nicht nur Teora anzeigen, sondern auch Teora erzeugen. Also dann exportiert man einfach ein Video aus seinen Standardprogrammen heraus. Der ist dann überall verfügbar. Das ist eigentlich eine schöne Sache. Ansonsten wird es halt immer gleich so richtig anstrengend und kompliziert, weil das die einzigen Frameworks, die so wirklich zur Verfügung stehen. Ich meine, die meisten Leute benutzen FFmpeg. Das haben wir ja auch schon erwähnt. Das verwendest du, glaube ich, auch sehr viel. Wenn man da Master of Disaster ist und die Kommandozahle träumt, dann kriegt man da sicherlich alles hin. Aber ich habe bisher so dermaßen viele Fehlschüsse gehabt, damit ich das nicht jedem empfehlen kann. Wie siehst du das mit Teora im Web? Und vielleicht kannst du auch noch mal ein bisschen was zu den Werkzeugen sagen, die man verwenden kann, um so einen Content zu erzeugen?
Also ich finde es eigentlich auch schade, dass man sich das nicht hat einigen können auf so einen Baseline-Codec. Und Teora wäre durchaus ein Baseline-Codec gewesen. Das Argument von Nokia war dann, lasst uns doch H261 nehmen als Baseline-Codec, weil, ja, den gibt es auch. Der könnte dann von mir aus auch gut genug sein.
Warum nicht gleich H263?
Ja, weil bei H261, der ist schon so alt, da sind die Patentansprüche weitgehend einfach abgelaufen. Das wäre dann im Prinzip eine sichere Sache. Aber da wäre Teora doch noch mal eine ganze Säge besser gewesen. Also die Argumentation, das ist nicht wirklich ehrlich, dass man Teora da so schlecht ansetzt. So schlecht ist es eigentlich gar nicht. Meines Erachtens nach, ist vielleicht auch einfach Geschmackssache. Zu den Werkzeugen, naja, unter Linux ist es gar immer so schlecht. Unter Linux habe ich halt den G-Streamer. Das scheint sich so als die Multimedia-Komponente da raus zu kristallisieren, in deren Lager drüben. Ich benutze inzwischen ja auch nebenan noch Ubuntu und bin damit halbwegs zufrieden, halbwegs glücklich. Und das läuft eigentlich ganz gut. Da kann ich dann auch sogar die ganz obskuren Sachen mal mit reinnehmen, noch einen Dirac in den Ock reinpacken und eine Vorbiss-Spur dazutun. Das ist eigentlich ganz witzig.
Was ist Dirac?
Dirac ist ein Wayflat-basierter Videocodec von der BBC Research.
Ah, ist das das Ding, was Sie in Ihrem Player dann verwenden?
Nein, leider nicht. Das ist auch nochmal eine ganz tragische Geschichte. Den Dirac benutzen Sie. Inzwischen geht er sogar in die Standardisierung. Scheinbar soll über die SMPTE der Dirac als Archivcodec standardisiert werden und wird dann da benutzt, um lange Zeit Archive zu machen, so etwas in der Richtung. Man könnte das vielleicht auch benutzen, um Delivery-Formate zu machen, die dann an den Enduser gehen und hart kompromiert sind. Aber da scheinen die Prozessoren noch nicht well genug zu sein, weil diese Well-Flat-Geschichten, wir hatten es ja vorhin schon erwähnt, die sind immer noch ziemlich rechenintensiv für aktuelle Prozessoren. Ist wohl noch nicht ganz so weit.
Okay, also Archivzwecke heißt, ist egal wie lange es dauert, das zu encodieren oder auch zu decodieren, weil Hauptsache, es ist klein und es sieht sehr gut aus.
Richtig.
Okay, das ist verständlich. Gut, ja, und du warst bei den Tools, FFmpeg und Dirac, und was?
Ja, genau, die Tools.
Mit G-Streamer kann man das gut zusammen machen.
Richtig, und die Linus G-Streamer, das ist dann gar nicht so schlecht. Also, das hat ungefähr die Qualität von dem, was man halt unter Windows und Mac OS X gewohnt ist, mit Direct Media und QuickTime. Das ist dann eben da der G-Streamer. Und der hat auch im Prinzip als sein favorisiertes Format. Ansonsten sieht es mal aus, das stimmt. Also, ich benutze auch selber den FFmpeg relativ viel. Und für meine Teora-Transcodings benutze ich dann FFmpeg2Teora. Das ist keine Fork, sondern halt eine Variante von FFmpeg, die speziell so rausgegeben wird, um Dollar-Format nach Teora zu codieren. Das funktioniert halbwegs gut. Da muss man sich keine großen Gedanken machen, dann wirft man irgendwas rein und hinten kommt Teora raus mit einer woebes Audio-Spur und dann war's das. Im Prinzip ist das auch das, was wir heutzutage machen beim RFA Ulm. Wenn wir unsere Veröffentlichungen machen von unseren Chaos-Seminaren, wir machen halt die Mpeg4-Sachen, weil wir die kennen und weil wir denken, dass die meisten das haben wollen und weil es vom Technischen her auch das Beste ist. Und machen dann so als kleines Bonus-Item für diejenigen, die es haben wollen, in der Regel gründen das besseren Support zu unserer Linux, was halt auch unsere Zielgruppe ist, dann noch diese Transcoding. Und das läuft so reinwerfen, durchlaufen lassen, dann ist es da und die freuen sich und es ist gut genug für sie.
Plötzlich haben wir mal über einen automatischen Konvertierer von dem Chaos-TV-Content nachgedacht. Da wird immer wieder viel angeklopft, aber es ist derzeit für mich zeitlich einfach nicht zu leisten. Ja, was wir nicht so richtig vorher angedacht hätten, deswegen weiß ich jetzt gar nicht, ob du da der richtige Ansprechpartner bist, aber weißt du, wie es sich mit den Lizenzzahlungen, die für MPEG 4 eigentlich tatsächlich anstehen, wie es sich da verhält? Es ist ein komplexes Feld. Also es ist auf jeden Fall so, Lizenzen müssen gezahlt werden von irgendjemand. Bloß in der Regel ist es halt so, wie auch bei MPEG 3, dass die Lizenzzahlungen für diese Medienformate, die so heftig patentiert sind und mit was weiß ich für Rechten ausgestattet sind, meistens vom Hersteller einer Encoder-Software bezahlt werden. Also es wird sozusagen auf die Produzenten geschoben bzw. auf die Werkzeuge der Produzenten. Das heißt, die Lizenzen werden dadurch abgeglichen, dass man eben Geld zahlt, wenn man diese Formate erzeugen, also wenn man ein Werkzeug verkaufen will, was diese Formate erzeugen kann. Was ja schon mal ein Problem ist, gerade wenn man jetzt bei freier Software sieht, was macht man, sowas wie FF MPEG produziert ja auch H264, also produziert MPEG 4 mit X264, Subsystem erzeugt es auch H264. Auch da müssen ja Lizenzen anfallen.
Also ich bin ja auch kein Rechtsanwalt, aber ich habe mich halt mit dem Thema ein bisschen beschäftigen müssen, weil die Fragen auch noch mal kommen und es ist ja auch wichtig. Mein aktueller Kenntnisstand ist der, dass man sich jede Komponente anschauen muss. Jede Komponente hat unterschiedliche Lizenzpflichten und Lizenzmodelle. Ich habe es vorhin schon mal kurz angesprochen. Es gibt zum Beispiel einen eigenen Patentpool für Leute, die Patente an ARC-Audio in dem Format halten. Es gibt einen eigenen Pool für Patente, die H264 betreffen, einen eigenen Pool für MPEG-2-Video, einen eigenen Pool für MPEG-3. Und die haben insofern unterschiedliche Lizenzmodelle als zum Beispiel bei ARC etwa nur für Decoder und Encoder Lizenzgebühren verlangt werden, sowohl in Hardware als auch in Software. Das heißt, der Hersteller des Decoders oder Encoders muss die Patentlizenzgebühren an diesen Patentpool zahlen, je nachdem, wie viele Lizenzen er verkauft von seinem Encoder oder Decoder-Produkt. Das heißt, eine Freie Implementierung dieser Standards müsste im Prinzip auch für jeden, der das downloadet, rein theoretisch in eine Form von Lizenzgebühr auch zahlen.
Es gibt aber Firmen, die das tun für Open Source. Mir fällt gerade das Beispiel nicht ein, aber ich weiß, dass es zumindest in einem Fall getan wird, dass es also einfach Firmen gibt, die der Meinung sind, das müsste jetzt mal stattfinden und die dann tatsächlich für die Existenz dieses freien Tools eben auch die Lizenzen beratten. Auch wenn die Community das nicht tut.
Ich glaube, Linux-Distributzonen machen das manchmal auch, dass man sagt, okay, wir nehmen jetzt von mir aus eine Real-Plattform, Hilix, mit einem MP3-Plugin und zahlen denen Lizenz und dann hat dieser kommerzielle Linux-Distributso dann das bezahlt und dann ist gut. Und dann hat man über diese Schiene eine legale Möglichkeit, MP3 abzuspielen. Das, was sonst gemacht wird, was ich ja zu kennen aus dem Netz, ist die Argumentation. Ja, wir stellen diesen MP3-Encoder oder x264 nur als Quellcode ins Netz und nur zu Forschung und Lehrezwecken und bieten keine Binaries an, die man als User runterladen kann und benutzen kann und argumentieren ebenso, dass wir dadurch nicht in die Pflicht genommen werden können, Lizenzgebühren zahlen zu müssen, weil das, was wir veröffentlichen, ist ja nicht in einem Zustand, wo man jetzt sagen kann, das ist schon ein fertiger Decoder oder Encoder, das muss man sich also übersetzen, konfigurieren hin und her. Das ist so die Grauzone, die meines Wissens zurzeit da gefahren wird. Das läuft, glaube ich, seit den populären MP3-Encodern. Lame ist da, glaube ich, derjenige, der das zuerst gemacht hat. Die haben sich halt hingestellt und gesagt, wir machen das nur zu Forschungszwecken. Und wer das dann übersetzt und für irgendwelche anderen Zwecke einsetzt, dann muss derjenige sich selber um die Lizenzgewöhnung kümmern.
So, das heißt, bei MP4 gibt es aber auch so verschiedene Lizenzmodelle, je nachdem, ob es gestreamt werden soll und so weiter. Aber jetzt so für normale Downloads, die man anbietet, also Podcasts, was ist da?
Also die Faustregel, gerade Hartz 264 hat so ein merkwürdiges Modell, dass man teilweise auch an den Downloads zahlen muss. Also nicht nur an Encoder oder Decodern, sondern an den Downloads. Die Faustregel ist die, immer wenn Geld fließt, möchte die Lizenzierungsgesellschaft mit verdienen. Das heißt, Pay-Per-View, Werbefinanzierung, Downloads, die man nur kriegt mit Mitgliedschaft irgendwo. Musik, was ist denn Musik? Da gibt es auch einen lustigen Namen für, dass man pro Titel zahlen muss. Immer wenn in irgendeiner Form Geld so fließt, dann möchten die da auch noch mal mit verdienen. Dann gibt es dann bestimmte Cent oder Prozentsätze, die dann gezahlt werden sollen bei solchen Modellen. Im Prinzip, wenn man solche Sachen komplett frei hat, kann man, glaube ich, da ganz rumkommen, irgendwas zahlen zu müssen. Aber es fängt halt schon an, wenn ich einen Banner auf meiner Webseite habe, bin ich dann schon verbefinanziert. Also es ist sehr schwer, da wirklich durchzukommen. Im Moment ist es noch nicht so schlimm. Es gibt noch ein Moratorium. Das wird gar nicht gemacht am Anfang, um ein Codec zu etablieren. Die ersten paar Jahre sagt man halt nichts. Und das ist dann alles frei und kein Problem. Und wenn es dann mal etabliert ist am Markt, dann fängt man an, die Daumenschrauben anzudrehen. Und ja, wir hätten ganz gerne da was dafür, weil wir da ja auch so viel Forschungsarbeit reingesteckt haben.
Aber das basiert alles auch auf den Patenten?
Richtig, genau.
Das heißt, wenn die verfallen, verfallen auch die Lizenzzahlungen?
Also das Argument mit H261 von Nokia für HTML5 war, dass H261 hinreichend alt ist, dass man da keine Angst haben muss, dass man da irgendwas zahlen müsste.
Aber jetzt wegen Patentsverletzungen?
Genau.
Was letztlich sozusagen in Folge dessen Lizenzzahlungen fällig werden würden? Das heißt, ob MPEG-4-Standard so sehr er jetzt mit Patenten bestückt sein sollte und solange auch die Liste von Lizenzzahlungen ist, irgendwann timet es aus?
Okay. Aber wann, das wissen wir jetzt im Einzelnen nicht, weil das hängt dann immer von dem jeweiligen Teil ab.
Ja, richtig. Also bei MPEG-4 wird es voraussichtlich noch eine ganze Weile dauern. Was ich vor kurzem mal wieder gelesen habe, die ersten Leute spekulieren schon darauf, dass MPEG-3 demnächst auslaufen wird. Also ich habe da jetzt allerdings auch Schätzungen gesehen zwischen 2009 und 2016. Aber 2009 wäre schon verdammt nahe. Und dann wäre MPEG-3 im Prinzip frei. Auch nicht schlecht.
Und ja, aber es gibt ja da auch noch Alternativen. Vielleicht sagen wir jetzt noch mal so als letzten Teil, nachdem wir jetzt so ausführlich über Video geredet haben, wir werden sicherlich zwischendurch noch mal drauf kommen, noch mal auf Audio eingehen, nachdem wir ja so auf Container und jetzt ausführlich die Video-Codecs hatten. Was, wie sieht es denn im Audio-Bereich aus? Also MPEG-3 ist natürlich jedem geläufig. Und das AU-Format von Sun hat ja dann nicht große Wellen geschlagen. Heutzutage scheint fast alles MPEG-3 zu sein, aber auch dort schleicht sich MPEG-4 rein. Auch hier im Wesentlichen beflügelt durch Apple, weil der iTunes-Store nur MPEG-4 Audio verkauft, beziehungsweise auch hier und da MPEG-4 Audio fürs Podcasting verwendet wird, weil es halt noch ein paar extra Features hat, die ganz nett sind. Aber ansonsten kann man sagen, MPEG-3 ist eigentlich überall. MPEG-3 ist, nicht MPEG-3, das haben wir schon gesagt, aber was ist MPEG-3?
MPEG-3 ist MPEG-1 Layer 3 Audio.
Das heißt?
Na ja, das kommt aus dem, ja, schon angestaubten MPEG-1 Standardpaket. Ja, Layer 3, ich glaube, das ist Kapitel 3 dann in diesem Standard gewesen. Da ist das spezifiziert worden.
Das ist der Layer 3.
Layer 3.
Es gibt ja auch Layer 2.
Das ist auch ein Audiokodek gewesen, glaube ich.
Der Layer 2 war von Anfang an drin. Das ist das, was im Radio verwendet wird. Das ist heute noch so der Standard. Wenn so der rasende Reporter vorbeikommt und sagt, ich möchte hier ganz gerne mal Live-Radio machen, dann stöpseln sie ihre kleine ESD-Inbox rein und machen über die 128 Kilobit halt dieses Layer 2. Aber MP3 ist dann sozusagen später dazugekommen und hat dann gesagt, wir sind jetzt noch ein bisschen besser. Das war also von der Qualität her besser und hatte mehr Optionen mit diesem ganzen VBR-Kram usw. Das kannst du hier vielleicht gleich nochmal erzeugen. Das ist ja dann das, was sich eigentlich erst so richtig durchgesetzt hat. Gut, über MP3 kann man eigentlich kaum reden. Das ist so omnipräsent. Trotzdem, es gibt auch immer wieder Probleme bei MP3. Das habe ich jetzt hier auch bei Chaosradio gemerkt. Man erst mal anfängt, mit unterschiedlichen Encodern zu arbeiten und mit unterschiedlichen Settings. Also so Optionen wie, was weiß ich, variable Bitrate und so weiter. Bitraten, die dann auch, sagen wir mal, nicht die Standardbitraten sind. Also wenn man nicht genau 128 Kilobit macht, sondern vielleicht nur 100 oder so, dann gibt es dann immer wieder so ein paar OJimin Flower Power Enterprises, USB-Sticks von Saturn. Die verschlucken sich dann einfach an den Dateien, weil sie sagen, das ist nicht das, was man zu Prozent hört. Das spiele ich gar nicht erst ab. Hast du auch Vergleiche gemacht bei Audiokodex, wie du es bei Videokodex gemacht hast?
Nicht persönlich so intensiv, weil ich nicht so wirklich Audiophil bin. Man hat halt dann, wenn man Videos veröffentlicht, dann immer die Frage, in welchem Format bringe ich das Audio raus? Wie viel Abtastrate reicht mir aus? Wie viel Betrate brauche ich in welchem Codec? Gerade solche Sachen, wie du erwähnt hattest, gibt es verschiedene Abtastraten in unterschiedlichen Versionen von MPEG-3. Das würde nicht unterstützt werden. Das ist MPEG-1 Layer 3 und MPEG-2, ich glaube auch Layer 3. Da sind dann mehr Abtastraten dazu gekommen, die unterstützt werden. Das war bei MPEG-1 Layer 3 noch ein kleinerer, eingeschränkter Bereich, der unterstützt werden musste. So etwas kriegt man halt dann bei der Zeit auch raus. Es geht in der Form, in der man es zurzeit verwendet, einfach so gut, dass man sich auf diesen kleinsten Gemeinsam-Nenner beschränken kann. Auch mit diesem Kilohertz, das ist auch alles kein Problem. Man nimmt halt diesen kleinsten Gemeinsam-Nenner aus MPEG-1 Layer 3 und Gutes. Selbst auf VBR kann man zur Not verzichten. Was gibt es noch? Das war es eigentlich. AAC als Nachfolgerformat war sogar schon bei MPEG-2 mit drin als Erweiterung. Hat damals aber übrigens niemand wirklich nennenswert benutzt. War in MPEG-4 dann der einzige Audio-Codec, der offiziell unterstützt wird und ist dann da gepusht worden, weil er halt der einzige Audio-Codec war. Da musste man AAC einsetzen. Das geht dann noch weiter. Da gibt es dann wieder Low-Complexity-Profile und High-Efficiency-Profile. Und Longtime hin und her gibt es inzwischen auch noch. Die Entwicklung geht immer noch weiter. Aber MPEG-3 ist halt gut genug. Ich sag immer MPEG-3, sorry. MPEG-1, Layer 3.
Okay, die freie Antwort heißt Warbis ist auch wieder Teil dieses Xip Foundation-Projektes. Und halt genauso frei, wie Theora frei ist. Das heißt, es kann vermutet werden, dass es keine Patentansprüche gibt, aber so richtig sicher ist man sich nicht. Klingt eigentlich ganz ordentlich, soweit ich das sagen kann. Also es gibt dann immer Leute, die fleißig die Chaosradiosendung als Org machen. Das sind dann kleinere Dateien, klingen aber eigentlich genauso. Wobei ich bin da überhaupt keine Referenz. Mein Gehör ist so verspult, da klingt eh alles scheiße. Von daher kann ich das nicht so richtig sagen. Aber diese ganz offensichtlichen Artefakte, die man doch kriegt, wenn man bei mp3 in zu niedrige Bitraten reingeht, also für niedrige Bitraten taugt es meiner Meinung nach einfach gar nicht, das habe ich da so noch nicht gehört. Aber ich habe es jetzt auch noch nicht wirklich bis zum Excess ausgespielt. Aber was ich vielleicht ganz interessant finde, ist die andere Entwicklung, nämlich dieses Flak, was so das einzige Open Source Audio- oder Medienformat ist, was tatsächlich eine interessante Nische füllt, weil es da eigentlich relativ wenig Alternativen zu geben scheint. Ist das richtig?
Ja, Flak ist ziemlich gut und hat den Markt für lossless Audio-Encoding auch ziemlich im Griff. Mir fällt sogar außer vielleicht diesem Allak.
Also muss man vielleicht nochmal kurz erklären, was Flak ist. Also es macht halt lossless Audio, wie dein Name schon so ein bisschen andeutet. Das heißt, es komprimiert die Daten, aber es vernichtet halt nichts in der Qualität. Es bleibt alles genauso erhalten. Man kann sich eine CD nach Flak rippen. Wie groß ist die dann? Was ist das? Ist das so Faktor 2 zu 1? Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Im Vergleich zu unkomprimiert ist es ungefähr 2 zu 1, ja.
Und ja, dann hat man einfach dasselbe, bloß eben mit weniger Platz. Also eine CD passt in 320 MB oder so. Oder?
Ja, und man kann guten Gewissens sagen, ich archiviere meine Stücke in diesem Flagg und da kann nichts passieren. Weil das ist halt 1 zu 1 das, wie ich es original hatte. Und dann muss ich mir keine Sorgen machen, wenn ich jetzt ursprünglich mal meine MP3s vor Jahren als 96 Kilobit pro Sekunde Format gerippt habe, dass ich die dann ein paar Jahre später vielleicht doch, wenn ich mal da mehr Qualität haben will, in einem anderen Format mit einem Webbit-Rate inkodieren will. Dass es nicht geht, dass ich wieder meine ganzen Original-CDs rauskramen muss. Sondern ich habe halt meinen Master. Und von diesem Master-Format kann ich ja dann auch noch beliebige, kleinere Encodings machen. Aber ich habe halt mal diesen Master und mit dem kann nichts passieren. Welt ist ja eins zu eins. Das ist eine sehr schicke Sache, wenn man sowas hat.
Das heißt, du benutzt es auch. In dem anderen Chaosradio Express Podcast zum ZFS-Datalsystem, was sehr interessant ist, fiel auch so das Stichwort, dass dort gegebenenfalls Flac als Modul sozusagen eingebaut wird, um so eine automatische Kompression zu machen. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo man seine Audiodateien abspeichert, dass sie dann eben, also wenn sie roh sind, also wenn man jetzt so IFF oder WAF hätte, so wie es eben direkt von der CD kommt, dass eben schon das Datalsystem automatisch dort entsprechend komprimiert, weil es eben dafür optimiert ist. Und das kann man halt machen mit diesen freien Formaten. Das ist ja eigentlich das schöne Ding, und wo ich auch durchaus noch eine Chance sehe, weil diese ganzen Lizenz- und Patent-Diskussionen, die sind extrem lästig. Also wenn man sich eigentlich anschaut, wie viel Fortschritte andere Bereiche gemacht haben, so in der Software-Technologie mit Bild und fast nicht alles für Formaten, da ist einfach dieser Audio- und Videobereich, ist einfach eklig. Man kann sich über MP3 schon sehr freuen, dass man da zumindest mal etwas gefunden hat, was eigentlich überall spielt. Im Videobereich ist das einfach auch heute noch nicht der Fall. Obwohl wir jetzt schon auf gut 15 Jahre oder 20 Jahre Entwicklungen zurückblicken, auf 15 ist es vielleicht realistisch, wo Videokodex entwickelt werden, gibt es bis heute einfach noch keinen wirklichen gemeinsamen Nenner und noch nicht mal die Bereitschaft, sich wirklich auf einen zu einigen. Also manche Leute haben diese Bereitschaft, aber die Meinungen darüber, was das eben sein sollte, die gehen dann doch immer wieder noch weit auseinander. Also das ist alles ein bisschen elend. Ja, und so zum Abschluss, was ist so, ja, weiß ich nicht, fällt dir noch was ein? Was Tolles?
Was Tolles?
Ja, was findest du denn toll?
Eigentlich fallen mir nur tragische Sachen ein, wenn ich ehrlich sein soll.
Tragisch?
Ja, ich hab schon so viele lustige Sachen gesehen, gerade in dem Bereich von Containern, was man so alles reinpacken kann oder in diesen riesen Stapeln von Standardisierungen und Spezifikationen, die man in so einem MP4-Bestandard drin hat. Das sind ja X-Kapitel, da sind Sachen drin wie Interaktivität, da gibt es dann Spuren, wo ich quasi Java reinkompiliert mitliefern kann, um solche Sachen wie DVD-Menüs in einem MP4-Container mitzuliefern, um eine ganze DVD in einen MP4-Container reinzustecken. Oder was ich mit diesen ganzen Textspuren alles machen kann, dass ich Videos Volltext durchsuchen kann, wenn ich auf einem Rechner Videodateien rumliegen habe, und dann kann ich mit Volltext-Suche, Spotlights, kenne ich jetzt halt mal speziell, irgendeinen Schlüssel, ein Stiefel eingeben und dann findet mir das Ding halt auch in meinen Videodateien die Szenen, die ich dann haben möchte. Das fehlt noch komplett, da wird es bei MPEG 7 noch mehr geben. Da sind sie gerade dran, dass es so der Trend, wo es dahin geht. Bei diesen DCT-basierten Video-Codecs scheinen so die Codec-Arbeiten mehr oder weniger durch zu sein. Mal gucken, was noch kommt, was natürlich schwer vorauszusagen. Aber so der Fokus in den nächsten Versionen von MPEG scheint wohl eher auf solche Metadaten zu gehen. Interaktivität haben sie eigentlich schon mehr oder weniger abgeschlossen. Mit MPEG 4 will bloß keiner benutzen aus irgendeinem Grund. Sogar Suche ist ein großes Thema. Ob eventuell solche XML-Geschichten reinkommen, so semantische Geschichten, um darin suchen zu können, wird man mal sehen. Da gibt es so viele Sachen. Bei QuickTime ist es mir bekannt, dass man früher solche Sachen hatte mit der QuickTime-Media-Layer. Dann konnte man QuickTime-VR-Szenerien in so einen Kontext reinpacken und dann 3D-Objekte mit reintun. Wir haben ja 4ML gar nicht angesprochen. Das war eine relativ große Sache, von der man sich viel versprochen hatte, dass man in 4ML-Szenen ein Video reinpacken kann.
Das war eine Totgeburt dieses Vorhandenes.
Ja, aber es waren ein paar lustige Sachen dabei. Ich erinnere mich an eine Sache. Das war, glaube ich, auch so ein Wave-LED-Bild-Format. Da konnte man in einen Film, in einen QuickTime-VR-Film, reinzoomen ohne Ende. Und hatte dann so diesen Power-of-Ten-Effekt, dass man ewig reinzoomen konnte, vom Weltall bis hin auf irgendeine Picknickdecke, so in der Richtung. Also da sind so viele Sachen, die noch Potenzial hätten, die nie wirklich auf den Markt gekommen sind, weil es den Leuten einfach genügt, wenn es Bild und Ton hat.
Ja, ich meine, das ist ja schon mal eine Errungenschaft, dass es überhaupt Bild und Ton gibt, weil wie schon erwähnt, also das scheint ja schon schwierig genug gewesen zu sein. Und deswegen ist ja YouTube und Konsorten da einfach mit Flash einfach jetzt auch so was Wichtiges gelungen, dass einfach überhaupt erst mal diese ganze Videodiskussion jetzt auch so weit angestoßen wurde, dass es langsam zur Finalisierung kommt. Ich denke festhalten kann man, es gibt freie Alternativen, die haben so ihre Probleme, ob sie wirklich patentfrei und lizenzfrei, also lizenzfrei werden sie sicherlich bleiben, zumindest von den Leuten, die es derzeit betreiben, ob sie dann so patentfrei sind, dass nicht doch noch irgendjemand da herkommen kann. Na ja, bin mir nicht so sicher, wenn schon jemand da einen Anspruch hätte, ob er da nicht schon längst den Finger gehoben hätte, aber da wo nicht so viel zu verdienen ist, ist das natürlich so eine Sache. Es gibt schon diverse kleine Hardware-Bausteine, die auch Teora und so weiter tatsächlich mit eingebaut haben. Also es ist durchaus möglich für so vertikale Anwendungen, dass sich das da auch noch mal durchsetzt an Sachen, wo es einfach sinnfrei ist, dafür Lizenzen zu zahlen. Oder wo, sagen wir mal, die Projekte nicht stattfinden könnten, weil sie einfach dann diese Kosten nicht tragen können. Aber ansonsten scheint sich zumindest derzeit ein bisschen der Weg in Richtung MPEG-4, H264, aufgemacht zu haben plus eben dem entsprechenden Audio AAC. Und die einzigen, die sich noch wehren, sind eigentlich Microsoft. Hab ich das halbwegs brauchbar zusammengefasst?
Das passt so, ja.
Okay, das passt so. Na fein, dann haben wir es jetzt zusammen. Stunde 50 Minuten haben wir schon durch. Und ja, ich bedanke mich, Michael, bei dir für die Ausführung.
Gerne.
Und wir werden ja demnächst noch ein bisschen Radio machen. Ansonsten war es das wieder bei Chaosradio Express. Die Ausgabe 61 ist hiermit beendet. Die letzte Ausgabe auch, die vor dem Kongress aufgezeichnet wird und ausgestrahlt wird. Ich hoffe, euch da alle zu sehen. Und ja, kommentiert fleißig bei uns im Blog, blog.chaosradio.ccc.de. Und wenn ihr weitere Anmerkungen habt zur Sendung, was nachtragen könnt, was hier falsch gesagt worden ist, ist sicherlich irgendwas dabei, weil gerade bei so einem komplexen Thema kriegt man das niemals gerade. Haben wir noch das Chaosradio-Wiki. Aber das habe ich jetzt alles schon tausendmal gesagt. Ich halte jetzt die Klappe und sage Dankeschön, Michael, und danke fürs Zuhören. Das war es bei Chaosradio Express. Wir sehen uns, bis bald.